L. SO. LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE GOOD
TO GO TO COMBAT YES EVERY YEP
HERE YOU YEAH ALL RIGHT THANKS.
GOOD MORNING WELCOME TO THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE HEARING. WHETHER YOU
ARE HERE IN PERSON WATCHING
VIRTUALLY OR ON THE PHONE. THIS
WILL BE A STORABLE HEARING AS
WE CONVENE AT IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER FLOOR.
TO START I WANT EXTEND A
SPECIAL THANKS TO ALL OF THE
STAFF THAT MADE A RETURN TO THE
CAPITAL IN ORDER TO HOLD.
LEGISLATIVE HEARINGS POSSIBLE.
PLEASE NOTE THE FOLLOWING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RANDY VOEPEL
HAS BEEN APPOINTED TO REPLACE
VICE CHAIR STEVEN CHOI FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL. THERE
ARE FOURTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA SIX ON CONSENT AS NOTED
ON THE AGENDA. ADDITIONALLY I
OFFICIALLY WELCOME THE NEWS
CONSULTANT TO THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE ALLEN
CAESAR RODDY MON MONROY. I
WOULD NOW LIKE TO GO OVER SOME
KEY ELEMENTS OF THE STRUCTURE
OF TODAY'S HEARING. DUE TO THE
CURRENT STAY AT HOME ORDER WE
ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON. WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR
THOSE PRESENT ON THE CHAMBER
FLOOR AND IN THE GALLERY. WE
ARE HAVING A PHYSICAL DISTANCE
IN PERSON HEARING. IN THIS
SPACE WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE AUTHORS. A MINIMAL
CONTINGENCY OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX
FEET OF SPACE. THERE ARE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE HERE TODAY IN THE
HEARING. ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY ON A BILL. PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND I WILL ASK YOU
TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD
ASK THE PUBLIC NOT TO TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM WHEN SHE FINISHED
TESTIFYING FOR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITOL. INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. IN ADDITION
TO BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM WE HAVE
SOME BILL WITNESSES MAKING USE
OF OUR WITH WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS WHICH ARE
LOCATED HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
THOSE WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON
THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING ROOM AND
ALSO ASK QUESTIONS TO THESE
WITNESSES. THERE MAY BE A
SLIGHT DELAY FROM THE STREAM
FROM THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM SO PLEASE BE
PATIENT. WE WILL ALSO BE USING
A MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE.
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY IN A BILL. THERE MAY BE
A SLIGHT DELAY SO GAIN I ASK
THAT ALL INVOLVED PLEASE REMAIN
PATIENT. THE PUBLIC TOLL FREE
CALLING AND NUMBER. FOR THE
HEARING. IS. ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS TWO FOUR. TWO SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THE
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV OR MONITOR
SCREEN. IF YOU ARE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO. AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON. IS IN THE
BEGINNING THE BILL DURING THE
BEGINNING OF THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A
BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE OF BACKGROUND
NOISE. THIS INCLUDES MUTING
YOUR LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND
YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE BE
SURE TO MUTE YOUR PHONE WHEN
YOU WERE NOT SPEAKING. ALSO BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A LEAD
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
AGAINST THE BILL. YOU WILL
REMAIN ON A LIVE LINE AND WILL
NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF. TELL
YOU'RE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE MODERATED PHONE SERVICE
PLEASE CALL THE COMMITTEE
OFFICE AT NINE ONE SIX. THREE
ONE NINE THREE NINE SIX SO. AND
COMMITTEE STAFF WILL DO THEIR
BEST TO ASSIST YOU. PLEASE NOTE
THAT WE ARE ALSO ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE.
ADDITIONALLY PLEASE NOTE THAT
OUR GENERAL GUIDANCE FOR BILLS
HEARD IN THIS COMMITTEE. IS TO
ALLOW TESTIMONY FOR TO LEAD
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT. AND TO
LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
SPEAK EACH FOR TWO MINUTES.
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND ENTITIES
THAT ARE NEITHER AND SUPPORT
NOR IN OPPOSITION WILL BE
ALLOWED TO GIVE TESTIMONY FOR
NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES WHEN I
CALL FOR TWEETERS. THE MEASURE
HAS MORE THAN TWO ENTITIES IN
THE TWEENER CATEGORY ONLY TWO
WILL BE ALLOWED TO SPEAK FOR
TWO MINUTES EACH. THANK YOU FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS THAT WE ALL FACE. FOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IN THE
CHAMBER. MEMBERS OF YOU'D LIKE
TO RESPOND TO A ROLL CALL ASK A
QUESTION PROVIDE A COMMENT.
I'LL NEED YOU TO RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONE SO STAFF CAN
ACTIVATED. WHEN THEY ARE
RECOGNIZING YOU TO SPEAK. FOR
AUTHORS OF BILLS EACH MEMBER-PRESENTED TODAY. WILL PROVIDE
AN OPENING AND CLOSING
STATEMENT. TO LEAD WITNESSES
WILL BE ANNOUNCED BY THE CHAIR.
AS I PREVIOUSLY STATED EACH
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY. BEFORE WE
PROCEED. SEE IF WE HAVE A POOR.
IF WE COULD HAVE THE SECRETARY
CALLED THE ROLE FOR ATTENDANCE.
MEDINA PRESENT MEDINA PRESENT
VOEPEL. VOEPEL PRESIDENT
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA PRESIDENT
BLOOM BLOOM PRESENT GABRIEL
GABRIEL PRESENT IRWIN. IRWIN
PRESIDENT KILEY. KILEY PRESENT
LEVINE LEVINE PRESIDENT LOW LOW
PRESIDENT PATTERSON. SANTIAGO
WEBER. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE A
QUORUM THANK YOU. BEFORE RIGHT
HERE IN THE FIRST BILL I'D LIKE
TO TAKE UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THE BILLS ON CONSENT ARE THE
ARE ON FILE AS AS FOLLOWS FILE
ITEM FOR A. B. TWENTY FOUR
NINETY FOUR. FILE ITEM SIX A.
B. THREE THREE SEVEN FOUR. FILE
ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY NINETEEN.
FILE ITEM EIGHT A. B. TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT. FILE ITEM
TEN A. B. TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR FILE ITEM THIRTEEN A. B.
TWENTY ONE NINETY. CAN I HAVE A
MOTION FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MOTION HAS BEEN FIRST AND
SECOND MADAM SECRETARY READ
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CALLING
THE ROLE IN THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MEDINA HI MEDINA HI
VOEPEL. WILL TELL HI ARAMBULA.
BLOOM BLOOM HI GABRIEL GABRIEL
HI IRWIN IRWIN HI KILEY KILEY
HI LEVINE LEVINE HI LOW HI LOW
HI PATTERSON. SANTIAGO WEBER
WEBER HI YOU MISTER CHAIR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS ENOUGH
BOTH. THANK YOU I CONSENT
CALENDAR IS PASSED I WILL LEAVE
THE OF ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO
BILLS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN WE
WILL HEAR BILLS AND FILE ORDER
BEGINNING WITH AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT FILE ITEM ONE.
WHEN YOU'RE READY PLEASE BEGIN
WITH YOUR OPENING STATE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN CALLING. WE
KNOW ONLY TOO WELL THE BASIC
NEEDS AND SECURITY HAS A DIRECT
IMPACT ON STUDENT ACADEMIC
SUCCESS. IN THE HARSH REALITY
IS A COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
ARE STRUGGLING TO MEET THEIR
BASIC NEEDS AT ALARMING RATES.
RELEASED IN MARCH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN BY THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND THE HOPE CENTER FOR
COLLEGE COMMUNITY AND JUSTICE.
FOUND A 19% OF THE SURVEY
STUDENTS RESPONDENTS
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS IN THE
PREVIOUS YEAR. 60% OF STUDENTS
WERE HOUSING AND SECURE IN THE
PREVIOUS YEAR AND 50% OF
STUDENTS WHO ARE FOOD INSECURE
IN THE PRIOR THIRTY DAYS. THESE
NUMBERS ARE HEARTBREAKING AND
IS CAMPUS IS A PHYSICALLY
CLOSED AND MOVED ONLINE CLASSES
DURING THE CLOVER NINETEEN
CRISIS. THE EXISTING BASIC
NEEDS CHALLENGES THEIR STUDENTS
FACE HAS BECOME EVEN MORE
PRONOUNCED AND URGENTLY REQUIRE
ACTION. COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
STEPPING UP TO MEET THE BASIC
NEEDSOF THEIR STUDENTS THROUGH
FOOD PANTRIES HOUSING RELATED
EFFORTS AND OTHER SERVICES AND
RESOURCES. HOWEVER FINDING
THESE RESOURCES OFTEN INCLUDES
NAVIGATING DISCONNECTED SYSTEMS
THAT CAN BE CONFUSING FOR
STUDENTS. THEREFORE AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT WOULD
PROVIDE A COORDINATED AND
INTEGRATED APPROACH TO MEET
STUDENTS BASIC NEEDS BY
ESTABLISHING A BASIC NEED
CENTER AND BASIC MEANS
COORDINATOR ON EACH COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CAMPUS ON OR BEFORE.
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THE BASIC NEEDS COORDINATOR
WOULD ACT AS A BROKER AND
IDENTIFYING SUPPORTING AND
LINKING STUDENTS TO ON AND OFF
CAMPUS SERVICES AND RESOURCES.
THE BASIC NEEDS CENTER IS
INTENDED TO BE A ONE STOP
CENTRALIZED LOCATION FOR
STUDENTS TO MORE EASILY ACCESS
IN AWARENESS AND BE CONNECTED
TO EXISTING SERVICES AND
RESOURCES. UNDER THIS BILL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WILL ALSO
DEVELOP A DOCUMENT THAT CLEARLY
LISTS ALL ON AND OFF CAMPUS
BASIC NEEDS SERVICES AND
RESOURCES THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE AT THE CENTER AS WELL
AS ON THE CAMPUSES WEBSITE AND
STUDENT PORTAL. AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT ALSO IDENTIFIES
POTENTIAL FUNDING SOURCES THEY
CAMPUSES MAY USED TO ESTABLISH
THE CENTER IN COORDINATOR SUCH
AS STUDENT EQUITY AND
ACHIEVEMENT PROGRAM FUNDING AS
WELL AS GIFTS AND DONATIONS.
THE IDEA OF A COORDINATED AND
INTEGRATED APPROACH IS NOT NEW.
IN FACT FIFTY THREE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAVE REPORTED HAVING
SOME FORM OF BASIC NEEDS CENTER.
DURING THESE UNPRECEDENTED IN
CHALLENGING TIMES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS ACROSS ALL
CAMPUSES NEED OUR SUPPORT NOW
MORE THAN EVER. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND I'M
HONORED TO BE JOINED BY TWO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
CATHERINE SQUIRE THE STUDENT AT
SAN JOAQUIN DELTA COLLEGE
REPRESENTING THE STUDENT SENATE
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WHICH IS THE BILL'S SPONSOR. AS
WELL AS MICHELLE KING THE
STUDENT AT JP COLLEGE WHO
WORKED AT HER COLLEGES BASIC
NEEDS CENTER. THANK YOU MISTER
BERMAN. AT AND T. MODERATOR THE
FIRST LEAD WITNESS ON THE LINE
FOR A. B. TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT IS CATHERINE SQUIRE
REGIONAL AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR
THE STUDENTS SENATE PER
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THE SQUIRE PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU ARE READY. ONE COMMITTEE
NUMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY MY NAME IS
NOT REQUIRED AND I'M AFRAID TO
ASK THEM LOOKING UP THE COLLEGE
AND DIRECTOR FOR THE-
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WHEN I FIRST HEARD ABOUT EIGHTY
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY EIGHT. I
THOUGHT BACK MY FIRST DAY OF
COLLEGE HOW AWFUL ABOUT. I
THANK MY THIRTY YEARS IN THE
DEATH OF A PARENT THE WORKING A
FULL TIME JOB TO HELP FEED MY
FAMILY. I KNOW THAT MY
COLLEAGUES HAD A FOOD PANTRY
AND MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES
THAT COULD HAVE PROVIDED BY
CHANGES SUPPORT. OFTEN CALLED A
CALL COLLEGE THEY MUST BE GOT
HELP BUT I WASN'T OUT. BECAUSE
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW. THEY
EXISTED TO BEGIN. THE STORY IS
NOT LONG EXPERIENCE. IT IS ONE
OF THE MOST TRAVEL PROBLEM
WHICH ARISE FOR STUDENTS ARE
FREE CENTURY. I THINK MY- BOB.
UNDOCUMENTED AND OTHER SIMILAR
TO. IF YOU. YOU LEVEL OF FRIDAY.
WITH NURSES FOR THE PERFECT. SO
NOT ABOUT OPTING FOR MORE BASIC
THREE FOUR AT THIS. THE ALREADY
A- LAKE AT THE MORE ACCESSIBLE.
ONLY FILL THE BECAUSE THAT
WOULD BE MORE BY. AB TWENTY
EIGHTY EIGHT WITH FURTHER WORK
HE YOU THINK. POLITY THAT COULD
THE- BUT OFF FEELINGS SHAME
UNDER. FOR OTHER COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN MY AREA ARE ALREADY
IN THE PROCESS OF ACQUIRING A
BASICALLY. DEMONSTRATING A RITE
AID TO ADDRESS THE
AFOREMENTIONED ISSUES. THIS IS
WHY ABSOLUTELY SIR IN AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT WELFARE
SYSTEM IN THE DIRECTION NEEDED
TO REPAIR FRAGMENTATION.
CONSIDER THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS
WITH. HOLISTIC MACINNES. WITH I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE COMMITTEE
NUMBER IS. AB THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT IN ORDER TO THAT THE-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS WIRE
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR THE
SECOND WITNESS CALLING IN IS
MICHELLE TO A STUDENT CHAFEE
COLLEGE IS TO PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU ARE READY. YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY BEFORE YOU TODAY MY
NAME IS MICHELLE TO AND I'M
EVEN AT THE BECAUSE- I WORK AT
I WORK AT MY COLLEGE THE BASIC
NEEDS. AND PROPER CAN AND
BENEFITS THE BENEFITS THAT IT
NEEDS THE PROVIDE IT. OUR BASIC
NEEDS THAT THEIR INCOME WITH
THE FACTORY WHERE I PRIMARY
WORK OFFERED FREE CAN.
MENTORING AND FIGHT THE BASE
BASIC WOULD YOU WALK MAT THE
TWO. YEAH PERHAPS. A ARE WHO
WORK ON PATRICK PROGRAM WHICH
IS THE PROGRAM HELPS ME BUT
BASS NEEDS TO STUDENTS BACK.
ELIGIBLE TO WITH CAR FOR THE
HOUSE AND. WE OFFER ALL HAVE AT
THE ONE BY CAO WORK IN CENTER
WELL AT THE STOCK TO OVER THE
EQUITY. HAVING BASIC NEEDS
CENTER VERY FOR STUDENTS AND
STUDENT ALWAYS CAME BACK IN
OFTEN WITH BRING THE FRIEND.
OVER FOR TO THE- I WOULD ALWAYS
HEAR STUDENT THE FOR HAVING ME
RESOURCES LOCATED ALL IN ONE
PLACE. OFTENTIMES THE FITTED
WITH XP INCLUDING VERY BUT ALSO.
HOUSING INSECURITY. SO IT JUST
MAKES A HAPPY RESOURCES LOCATED
TOGETHER. I OFTEN WOULD HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH STUDENTS HOW
THEY WISHED THE COLLEGES WHAT
HAVE HAD THANK YOU. FOR
RESOURCES AT. THIS IS WHY I ASK
YOU TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT PROVIDE ALL
STUDENTS WITH THE BENEFITS OF
ESSENTIAL LIKE I. THINK YEAH.
THANK YOU MISS TO WE WILL NOW
MOVE THE PUBLIC COMMENT. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER
FLOOR. OR IN THE GALLERY. IF SO
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES OPPOSITE IN
OPPOSITION IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER FOR. SCENE NINE. ANY
TWEENER. LOCAL SO MOVING OUT OF
THE PHONE LINES EIGHTEEN ANTI
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE OR ON IN THE QUEUE.
PLEASE BE SURE TO MEET YOUR
PHONE WHEN YOU'RE NOT SPEAKING.
THANK YOU IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
AT THIS TIME AGAIN THAT'S ONE
THAN ZERO ONE MOMENT BUT.
HOW
DOES NOT A MOMENT. ONE IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. EIGHTEEN
T. MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AT AT
THIS TIME ON THE PHONE NUMBER
IN THE QUEUE. I BELIEVE SO IF
THERE IS ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE
HAVE A LINE FORTY EIGHT ON THE
PHONE LINE FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS MIKE RILEY
KINCAID BUT PUBLIC ADVOCATE AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU.
ONE OF THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
ANY WITNESSES ON THE QUEUE ARE
ON THE PHONE IN THAT ARE
TWEETERS. FOR THAT YOU MAY ALSO
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT'S ONE
ZERO.
AND WE DO ONE MOMENT
PLEASE SIR.
THAT COMES FROM
LINE FIFTEEN BLIND FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. HELLO. WHICH
WE CAN HEAR YOU YEAH YOU CAN BE
HEARD. ON I APOLOGIZE SIDE-
GOOD MORNING CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS AN
RUN WHICH IT AND I AM WITH
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SHOPS OF OFFICE WE DO NOT HAVE
A POSITION ON THE SPELL BUT WE
APPRECIATE. THAT I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING FOR FURTHER WITH THE
AUTHOR BILL SPONSORS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. STE. THE
FIRST AND SECOND ARE TO MISTER
BERMAN ANY CLOSING STATEMENTS.
BROUGH THANK YOU. BUT I THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD THAT ADDRESSES THE
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS IN THE WAKE
OF CLOVER NINETEEN IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE IS THE
LEGISLATURE CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
THE TOTAL RISING COST OF
ATTENDANCE FOR STUDENTS AND
THIS INCLUDES STUDENTS HOUSING
AND FOOD AND SECURITIES AB
EIGHT TWENTY THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
PROVIDES A REASONABLE SOLUTION
FOR HELPING STUDENTS NAVIGATE
THE OFTEN CONFUSING WEB OF
RESOURCES AVAILABLE. TO THEM
FROM THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVING A SINGLE LOCATION IN A
SINGLE COORDINATOR WHOSE
PURPOSE IS TO LINK STUDENTS
WITH AVAILABLE RESOURCES WILL
BE VENN BENEFICIAL IN THESE
UNCERTAIN TIMES THE MOTION
BEFORE US IS DO PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY IF YOU'D PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA HI MEDINA I WILL TELL.
WILL TELL AROUND WE LIVE.
ARAMBULA HI BLOOM. BLOOM HI
GABRIEL. THE REAL HI IRWIN.
IRWIN HI KILEY KILEY HI LEVINE
LEVINE HI LO LO HI PATTERSON
PATTERSON HI SANTIAGO. WEBER
WEBER HI. THE VOTE IS CURRENTLY
ELEVEN TWO ZERO MISTER CHAIR.
ELEVEN ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT MR
BERMAN- I LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THE NEXT BILL
AND FILE ORDER IS AB TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR WHEN YOU ARE
READY MISTER BERMAN THESE
PRISSY. THANK YOU MISTER JACK
COLLEAGUES I WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL
WILL BE EXCEPT ACCEPTING THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENT DESCRIBING
THE ANALYSIS WHICH WOULD ENSURE
THAT THE BILL APPEARS TO BE A
CONTENT THE PROPOSITION. THIRTY
SEVEN. CURRENTLY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT. CALIFORNIA
STATE LOTTERY FUNDING SOME OF
WHICH IS DEEMED RESTRICTED AND
CAN ONLY BE USED FOR THE
PURPOSE OF INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS HOWEVER OVER 60% OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT HAVE
A SURPLUS OF THESE RESTRICTED
LOTTERY FUNDS LEAVING OVER
EIGHTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS ON
TOUCH. THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT TO
USED TO ALSO USE RESTRICTED
LOTTERY FUNDS TO PROVIDE
HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND FOOD
ASSISTANCE TO STUDENTS THIS
BILL FURTHERS THE PURPOSES OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LOTTERY
ACT BECAUSE AS HAS BEEN
RECOGNIZED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND LEADERS LIKE THE
HOPE CENTER FOR COLLEGE
COMMUNITY AND JUSTICE AT TEMPLE
UNIVERSITY HOMELESSNESS AND
FOOD SECURITY ARE TWO OF THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS. TO
STUDENTS ABILITY TO STAY IN
SCHOOL AND ACHIEVE THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS PROVIDING
HOUSING ASSISTANCE FOOD
ASSISTANCE WILL IMPROVE CALL
COMPLETION RATES PERSISTENCE IN
CREDIT LIMIT IT'S HARD TO ARGUE
THAT WAS AREN'T INSTRUCTIONAL
PURPOSES. CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS WERE ALREADY
STRUGGLING WITH HUNGER HOUSING
AND SECURITY AND PROCESS FOR
COVERT NINETEEN NOW CAMPUS
CLOSURES HAVE CREATED NEW
EXPENSES AT THE SAME TIME THAT
STUDENTS OR THEIR FAMILIES MAY
HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS THIS BILL
IS EVEN MORE NEEDED TO THE
CURRENT CRISIS HELPING TO
BRIDGE GAPS FOR THE STATE'S
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS WILL
NOT REQUIRING. ANYTHING THAT.
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. AND I'M TO HAVE BROAD
SUPPORT FROM COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DOES. THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE.
STUDENT GROUPS AND FACULTY
ORGANIZATIONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND WITH
BACK ON TO TESTIFY TODAY ARE
DEBBY KLEIN PRESIDENT. OF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND GENEVIEVE KOHLER STUDENT
TRUSTEE AND BEYOND THE CALL.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN. EIGHTY
ANTI MODERATOR WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO THE FIRST LEAD WITNESS WHO'S
CALLING IN FOR AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FOUR. DEBBY KLEIN MISS
KLEIN IS PRESIDENT OF FACULTY
ASSOCIATION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. MISS KLEIN
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I'M DOCTOR DEBBIE
CLIMATE PROFESSOR OF
ANTHROPOLOGY AT GAVEL IN
COLLEGE AND THE PRESIDENT OF
THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THE STATE WIDE ORGANIZATION
THAT REPRESENTS OVER NINE
THOUSAND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY AND THE PROUD SPONSOR
OF THE BILL LIKE KATE TWELFTH
COMMUNITY COLLEGES RECEIVE
STATE LOTTERY FUNDING THIS
FUNDING IS SPLIT INTO TWO
CATEGORIES UNRESTRICTED AND
RESTRICTED. IT GETS DONE TO BE
SPENT ON A NUMBER OF ITEMS
INCLUDING SALARIES AND ANYTHING
DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE
EDUCATION OF OUR STUDENTS.
RESTRICTED LOTTERY FUNDS ON THE
OTHER HAND CAN ONLY BE USED ON
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS WHILE
MOST DISTRICTS THAN ALL OF
THEIR UNRESTRICTED FUNDS EVERY
YEAR THE SAME IS NOT THE CASE
FOR RESTRICTED FUNDS. WE PULLED
BUDGET REPORTS FROM SEVENTY ONE
DISTRICT AND DISCOVERED AT
LEAST FORTY TWO DISTRICTS HAD A
SURPLUS OF RESTRICTED LOTTERY
FUNDS MY COLLEGE GAVEL AND HAD
NOT SPENT OUR ALMOST EIGHTY TWO
THOUSAND A RESTRICTED LOTTERY
FUNDS IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. THAT
WAS ON THE LOW SIDE A TWENTY
NINETEEN SOME DISTRICT HAD A
SURPLUS AT FIVE POINT SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION. INSTEAD OF
LETTING THIS MONEY IN THE
ACCOUNT AND ROLL OVER FROM YEAR
TO YEAR DISTRICTS HAVE THE
OPTION OF USING IT TO FULFILL
THE INTENT OF THE VOTERS.
DISTRICTS COULD BEUSING THE
FUNDS TO SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS
BASIC NEEDS WHICH WOULD ENSURE
THEIR ACADEMIC SUCCESS. I
FACULTY WHO WORK WITH STUDENTS
EVERY DAY WE KNOW THAT BASIC
NEEDS AN ACADEMIC SUCCESS ARE
INEXTRICABLY LINKED. WHEN MY
STUDENTS ARE WORRIED ABOUT
WHERE THEY WILL GET THEIR NEXT
MEAL AND WHERE THEY WILL SLEEP
AT NIGHT THEY'RE NOT LIKELY TO
SUCCEED IN MY CLASSES. WITH THE
CODED NINETEEN CHILDREN PLACE
ORDER AN UNPRECEDENTED RATE OF
JOB LOSS OUR STUDENTS ARE
STRUGGLING NOW MORE THAN EVER.
AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY FOUR
WOULD OPEN UP A CURRENTLY UNDER
UTILIZED FUNDING SOURCE IT
WOULD GIVE THE DISTRICTS
ANOTHER TOOL FOR HELP OUR
STUDENTS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR STATEMENT
MODERATOR THE NEXT WITNESS
CALLING. IS GENEVIEVE COLA. THE
STUDENT THE ANSWER. MS COLE ARE
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE. MY
NAME'S JOHN VEHICLE ARE I'M A
STUDENT AT THE END THE COLLEGE
IN CUPERTINO AND I'M GRATEFUL
TO BE. AND SUPPORT THIS BILL
I'M HOUSING. AS NEW FOR. I
FOUND AFFORDABLE HOUSING AT
AND- I RECEIVED ACTED TO A NO
CONTRADICTION AND SEVEN RUN
REACHES THAT LOOKING STRUGGLING
TO FIND HOUSING IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE ACADEMIC TERM MY COLLEGE
DIDN'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
HELP ME FOR EXAMPLE BUT THE
UNEXPECTED NEWS INDICATED YOU
DEPOSIT. SO INTERLINKS LIKE
BECOMING A TEST SUBJECT FOR
MEDICAL TREATMENT IN ORDER TO
MAKE MONEY NEEDED TO SAY HOW I
STRUGGLED IN SCHOOL FOR ALL THE
TERMS BY HOUSING SITUATION WITH
UNSTABLE CONSTANTLY CONSIDER
DROPPING OUT IN ORDER TO WORK
MORE WITH CONSTANTLY AGES EVEN
AFTER FINDING A NEW PLACE TO
LIVE. HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
COMMUNICORP CHANGE EXPERIENCED
HOMELESSNESS THE PAST YEAR AND
OVER A MILLION OF US EXPERIENCE
HOUSING AND FOOD INSECURITY IF
CONDITION TO BE IN SURVIVAL
MODE THE PEOPLE AT YOUR LIFE
AND MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE. TO
FOCUS ON ACADEMIC. NO THAT THEY
WILL FOUNDATION OF. NO THREE
THE BENEFITS OF AT. FOR EVERY
STORY THERE ON STORY OF MY WERE
TO DELAY OR DISCONTINUE THE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR MORE
STORIES. A PROACTIVE SUPPORT
LEADING TO SUCCESS. THIS BILL
REPRESENTS RESOURCEFULNESS AND
RESPONSIVENESS TO THE FOR THE
COLLEGES ALLOWING THEM TO BE
MORE FLEXIBLE WITH FUNDS. TO
HELP MARCH STUDENT. A THREE
PHASE AND PENDING BUDGET CUTS
INCREASE STUDENT NEED THIS BILL
WILL HELP STOCKTON THE IMPACT
OF CODE NINETEEN. THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE ASKED TO DO THE
IMPOSSIBLE PROVIDING HIGHER
EDUCATION AND SOCIAL MOBILITY
TO INCREASINGLY STRAINED AND
FINANCIALLY UNSTABLE
COPULATION. AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FOUR WILL MAKE DOING THE
IMPOSSIBLE A LITTLE EASIER.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TOUCH BY AND FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION FOR HIS. IT
REALLY MEANS THE WORLD TO HAVE
ADVOCACY FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SHOULDN'T BE IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU MISS
CALLER WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT IN THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBER OR IN THE
GALLERY. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER FLOOR OR IN THE GALLERY.
ANY CLEANERS IN THE BACK OF THE
SEE NINE WILL MOVE ON TO THE
PHONE LINES EIGHTEEN ANTI
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE OR ON THE QUEUE. Q. IF
THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR. I THANK YOU
MODERATOR ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE OR IN
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU THOSE IN
OPPOSITION MAY ALSO PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME SIR. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU MODERATE A ANY CLEANERS ON
THE PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE. WE
DO HAVE SOMEONE IN Q. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO ONE
MOMENT PLEASE.
Q. LINE FIFTY-
LINE IS OPEN AT THIS TIME
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHEN COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS THURMOND **** AND I AM WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHAPTERS OFFICE WE DO
NOT HAVE A POSITION TODAY BUT
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL
THAT. WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
ARTHUR SPONSORS FOR TEN
APPLYING AN ADDITIONAL SOURCE
OF FUNDS THAT CAN BE USED TO
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS DURING
THIS DIFFICULT BUDGET TIMES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MR LIVING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU TO THE OFFER I KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN FOLLOWING THESE
ISSUES FOR A LONG TIME TRYING
TO HELP PEOPLE AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND I ADMIRE AND I
RESPECT THAT AL SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY PROBABLY YOU KNOW AS
IT MOVES THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY
ALL SUPPORTED. I DO WISH THAT
WE COULD SUPPORT IT WITH MONEY
FROM ANOTHER PLACE- HIGH- DO
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT IT THE
LOTTERY YOU CAN AS THE MARKET
ALLOW PEOPLE TO DREAM AND HAVE
A DIVERSION WHICH SOMETHING WE
ALL PROBABLY NEED A LITTLE BIT
MORE OF RIGHT NOW. THAT WE
KNOW- REALLY PRAISE UPON THE
POOREST CALIFORNIANS AND TAKES
MONEY FROM THE POOREST
CALIFORNIANS AND IF WE COULD
JUST FUND OUR SCHOOLS HAD JUST
GENERALLY- BETTER WE WOULDN'T
HAVE TO RELY ON A LOTTERY THAT
TAKES MONEY FROM THE POOR-
ESSENTIALLY JUST. MULTIPLE
TIMES EVERY WEEK. THAT JUST
THEY CAN'T AFFORD MOST LIKELY
SO I SAW ALSO PORT THIS BUT I
WISH THAT WE COULD FIND THESE
THINGS IN A DIFFERENT WAY THANK
YOU. MR BOVELL. YES MISTER
CHAIR- I'M A NO I'M A NOT VOTE
ON THIS ONE I WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW WHY I HAD CONCERNS- NUMBER
ONE IS THE LOTTERY RECENTLY
THROUGH THE STATE COMPTROLLER
AND THE- GOVERNOR AND I'M NOT
QUITE SURE WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE- CAME IN ON THIS
LOWERED PRIZES AND EDUCATION
FROM 87% 84% AND REALLY
TROUBLING TO ME IS OVERHEAD FOR
THE LOTTERY. WENT FROM 30% 216%
THAT'S A 6% CHUNK OUT OF THE
MONEY THAT WAS GOING BASICALLY
THE EDUCATION THAT CONCERNS ME
GREATLY. ALSO THERE MAY BE A
QUESTION DOWN THE ROAD ABOUT
THE CONSTITUTIONALITY-
SPECIFICALLY AB ONE FORTY TWO
HIGH I SEE IN. TWO THOUSAND
TEN. CHANGE THE LOTTERY WITHOUT
A VOTE OF THE PEOPLE NOW
HOWEVER AB ONE FORTY TO
INCREASE PRIZE AWARDS SO IT'S
UNLIKELY THE PUBLIC WOULD HAVE
SUED SO THE LEGISLATURE KIND OF
SLID BY THAT ONE. NOT QUITE
SURE HOW THIS WOULD GO. ON AND
THEN FINALLY IT JUST TO WRAP IT
UP. HELPING THE HOMELESS
PROVIDING FOOD ASSISTANCE AND
HOUSING ARE WORTHY CAUSES AND I
SUPPORT THOSE CAUSES BUT IT'S
NOT PART OF THE MAIN MISSION OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THERE MAIN
MISSION IS TO PROVIDE EDUCATION
AND MY CONCERN IS IF YOU GET
OFF INTO THE WEEDS HERE. YOU'RE
NOT AS EFFECTIVE IN EDUCATING
OUR SERVICES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
MISTER VOEPEL ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. TO SEE
NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROVIDE
A CLOSING STATEMENT IRA
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. ESPECIALLY AFTER
I'VE OF. AGAIN THANK YOU MISTER
BERMAN FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND FOR ACCEPTING THE
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS PROPOSED
BY THE COMMITTEE. DO THE
RESTRICTIONS PLACED ON
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
MANY OF THE CALIFORNIA LOTTERY
FUNDS INTENDED FOR
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS HAVE
REMAINED ON ALLOCATED TO THE
LACK OF NEED. IN THE WAKE OF
THE CURRENT. PANDEMIC IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDE THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WITH EVERY
AVENUE POSSIBLE TO MAXIMIZE THE
USE OF THE EXISTING FUNDS FOR
THE BENEFIT OF STUDENTS. AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR DOES
EXACTLY THIS BY ENSURING
UNALLOCATED RESTRICTED LOTTERY
FORMS CAN BE SED FOR MULTIPLE
PURPOSES FOR THE BENEFIT OF ALL
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS. DO I HAVE A MOTION
FOR THIS BILL. FIRST AND SECOND
ARE THE MOTION BEFORE US IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEDINA I MEDINA-
FULFILL. VOEPEL NOT VOTING
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI BLOOM
BLOOM HI GABRIEL. GABRIEL HI
IRWIN IRWIN HI KILEY. KILEY NO
LEVINE LEVINE HI LO LO HI
PATTERSON PATTERSON HI SANTIAGO.
WEBER WEBER HI. THE VOTE IS
CURRENTLY NINE ONE MISTER CHAIR.
NINE ONE YOUR BILL IS OUT.
WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. THE NEXT BILL
FOLLOW ORDERS AB TWENTY THIRTY
BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN BLANCA RUBIO.
AS RUBIO PLEASE PROCEED WITH
YOUR OPENING STATEMENT WHEN YOU
ARE READY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR NUMBERS. TODAY I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE CONTINUE WORK
DURING THIS UNIQUE LEGISLATIVE
SESSION I KNOW THIS IS THE NEW
NORMAL FOR ALL OF US SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK I
BELIEVE THAT IT IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURE EVERY STUDENT HAS ACCESS
TO FUNDING FOR COLLEGE AND COST
SHOULD NEVER BE THE FINAL
DETERMINATION. ARE WHEN
CHOOSING A COLLEGE TO ATTEND
THAT IS WHY I AM VERY EXCITED
TO AUTHOR ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THIRTY THE COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITIES ACT THIS BILL
WILL BRING STABILITY TO THE CAL
GRANT AWARDS BY IMPLEMENTING IN
YOUR WORK FUNDING FORMULA FOR
STUDENTS ATTENDING PRIVATE NON.
I'M PROFIT UNIVERSITY I'D LIKE
THE WORD FOR THE UC AND HIS
VIEWS ON THAT ARE TESTED BASED
ON CHANGES IN TUITION ENERGY
AWARD ALLOCATION FOR PRIVATE
NONPROFIT UNIVERSITIES WAS SET
TO A STATIC AMOUNT IN THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
UPON. SUCCESSFUL AB TWENTY
THIRTY CAL GRANT AWARDS FOR
PRIVATE NONPROFIT COLLEGES I
JUST WITH FUTURE INCREASES IN
ALLOCATION FOR EQUIVALENT- THE
STATE COLLEGES. CAL GRANT
AWARDS PROVIDE CRITICAL
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO
STUDENTS AND OUR CAN OFTEN BE
THE FINAL DETERMINATION OF
SCHOOL ACCESS. NOT ONLY DOES
THE CALVET PROVIDING AFFORDABLE
PATHWAY TO COLLEGE IT SERVES A
SIGNIFICANT POPULATION OF A
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS. IN FACT
NEARLY HALF OF CAL GRANT
RECIPIENTS ARE LATINOS. AS A
LATINA WHO ATTENDED THIS IS A
PACIFIC UNIVERSITY FOR BOTH MY
UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE AND A
MASTER'S DEGREE THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS BILL PERSONALLY
RESONATES WITH ME. WITH KOBE
THEM HAPPEN FAMILIES PREPARING
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION ACROSS THE
STATE IT IS CRUCIAL THAT WE
INCREASE ACCESS TO COLLEGE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. WHO SO
THAT STUDENTS FINANCIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES DO NOT DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY CAN AFFORD
COLLEGE. THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
TO PRESENT CALLING IN TODAY TO
TESTIFY IS ALEX GRAVES WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AS WELL AS
ASSIST ALEXANDER GóMEZ FOR THE
CABINET RECIPIENT AT FRESNO
PACIFIC UNIVERSITY. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MOST WOMAN RUBIO
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR THE FIRST
LEAD WITNESS CALLING IN FOR AB
TWENTY THIRTY. IS ALEX GRAVES
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR THE
EIGHT I SEE SEE YOU. MISTER
GRAVES PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU
ARE READY. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME DOLLARS
GRAVES AT THE I. T. FIELD. THAT
THE SPONSORS ON A FIRST BANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR RECOGNIZING THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF THIS
POLICY PARTICULARLY AND I'M
CERTAIN TIME THAT WE FIND
OURSELVES AND- EIGHTY
REPRESENTS EIGHTY FIVE
INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES IN THE STATE.
AND COLLECTIVELY EDUCATE
HUNDRED NINETY NINE THOUSAND
UNDERGRADUATE AND IT IS OUR
STUDENTS THAT I'D LIKE TO SPEAK
ABOUT. NEARLY THREE QUARTERS OF
OUR UNDERGRADUATES ARE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. ARE
SECTOR EDUCATE OVER TWENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND CAL GRANT
STUDENTS. HALF OF HIM OR THE
FIRST IN THEIR FAMILIES TO
ATTEND COLLEGE. OUR GRANT
PROGRAM IS A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE STATE DIDN'T AN
INSTITUTION TO HELP ENSURE COST
NOT A BARRIER TO THE PURSUIT OF
A COLLEGE DEGREE. STUDENTS
ATTENDING A USED HERE IF YOU
THE COMMITMENT IS CLEAR. IF YOU
ARE LOW INCOME YOUR TUITION
WILL BE COVERED BY THE CAL
GRANT AWARD. IN A CERTAIN P.
PRISTINE THEIR FAMILY THIS
CRITICAL AND SOMETHING THAT HAS
NOT BEEN PROVIDED TO SIMILAR
STUDENTS WHO CHOOSE TO ATTEND
OUR SECTOR. TWO THOUSAND ONE
THE CALIBRATION WORK FOR
STUDENTS IN OUR SECTOR HAS BEEN
A DISCRETIONARY BUDGET ITEM
INTO UNDERSCORE THE NEED FOR
THIS BILL I'D LIKE TO POINT TO
THE PAST. FOLLOWING THE
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN IN THE EARLY
TWO THOUSANDS. TWO THOUSAND FOR
THE CALIFORNIA WORK FOR
STUDENTS ATTENDING OUR SECTOR.
BUT CUT FROM NINE THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHT DOLLARS
280-003-0020 TWO DOLLARS. AND
AFTER SOME REINVESTMENT BALLING
THE GREAT RECESSION THE WORD
WAS CUT AGAIN. FOR NINE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
EIGHT DOLLARS TO NINE THOUSAND
EIGHTY FOUR DOLLARS BY TWENTY
THIRTEEN. ANYWHERE DID NOT
INCREASED INSTEAD. IN IN TOTAL
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. THE
CALDERON AWARD INCREASED UNDER
92% FOR STUDENTS ATTENDING A
FEW A FEW. 118% PER STUDENT
ATTENDING A UC BUT OVER THAT
SAME TIME PERIOD DECREASED
EXPERTS THAT OUR STUDENTS
ATTENDING OUR INSTITUTIONS. IS
CUT TIME STUDENT WHO BUY
ANYTHING GIVEN THE ECONOMIC
MEASUREMENT HAVE SIMILAR NEED
TO THE CAL GRANT RECIPIENTS
ATTENDING OUR PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS. YEAH WELL THEIR
COUNTERPARTS HAVE A GUARANTEE
CAL GRANT AWARD. EQUALLY
DESERVING STUDENTS HAVE NO SUCH
BASELINE. THAT THE STATE
GOBBLED UP HOW TO RESPOND TO
THE KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY IT IS
CREATED. POLICIES SUCH AS THAT
ARE CRITICALLY NEEDED TO
PROTECT AND SUPPORT
CALIFORNIANS. ON BEHALF OF THE
TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND CAL GRANT
STUDENTS WE EDUCATE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR BRING
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THEIR
EDUCATIONAL PURSUITS SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER RANGE EIGHTEEN ANTI
MODERATOR THE SECOND WITNESS
CALLING IN THIS. IS HAS SEUSS
ALEXANDER GOMEZ THE STUDENT AT
FRESNO PACIFIC UNIVERSITY. MR
GOMEZ PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLY OF HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE IT IS A PRIVILEGE TO
BE ABLE TO TELL YOU ABOUT
MYSELF THE DOORS WIDE ACCOUNT
AND NOT ONLY IMPORTANT TO ME
BUT TO OTHER STUDENTS IN THE
BACK MANY MESSAGES ALEXANDER
GOVERNMENT ANY POLITICAL
SCIENCE MAJORS IN THE FRESNO
PACIFIC UNIVERSITY I MEAN FIRST
UNIVERSAL DIDN'T THE OWNERS OF
THREE AND A HALF OF THE BY. THE
MY COLLEGE EXPERIENCE I BEGAN
TO UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT AND
THAT DID THE COMMENTED TO ME
AND OTHER TO BEGIN WITH THE CAL
GRANT TO THE STORES OF
NECESSARY FUNDING FOR STUDENTS
LIKE ME WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO BE
A STUDENT LIKE ME. I'M IN NAME
WILL COME FROM A LOW INCOME
BACKGROUND BECAUSE I THOUGHT I
CONNECTED WITH ONLY ONE PARENT
BEING THE TO PROVIDE FOR FIVE
PEOPLE I UNDERSTAND THERE ARE
OTHERHARD WORKING STUDENTS TO
JOIN IN A FIGHT WITH THE
BACKGROUND WHICH IS MINE BUT
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN MATTERS
THAT STATE IT'S NOT EASY BEING
HIT WITH DOGS TO CONSIDER AND
SO MUCH TO DO. BUT WE ALL WORK
HARD AND BECAUSE DEFINING TO DO
THE CAL GRANT STUDENTS THINK
WE'LL CAN'T RECEIVE ANY FEDERAL
FUNDING ARE ABLE TO ATTEND
UNIVERSITY SUCH AS FRASER AMONG
OTHER AND UNIVERSITY. RED DOOR
I'D LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THAT WILL
THE BILL LIKE AB TWENTY THIRTY
TO GET PAST BECAUSE WILL TEND
TO LIKE TO DATE WE DO NOT KNOW
WHEN OUR EDUCATIONAL CLIPPERS
WILL BE AT RISK HE CALLED IN
NINETEEN SAMPLE MANY
INSTITUTIONS IRVINE WAY. HUMOR
TO CONDEMN IT AND IT IS
UNFORTUNATE THAT SOME OF THE
STUDENTS WHO WILL BE AFFECTED
MUCH MORE THAN OTHER STUDENTS I
LIKE ON THE NINETEENTH THEIR
OTHER UNCERTAINTIES THAT ARE
BOUND TO BE PROBLEMS WHICH
INCLUDE MAKE IT SHIPS THAT. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MAY NOT FIND
ME IF CALIFORNIA CAN MOTIVATED
AS MUCH TO BE ABLE TO GET BACK
IN THE FUTURE FOR EVERY DOLLAR
THAT WAS SPENT ON MY EDUCATION
AND EVEN MORE YEAH MAYBE KINDA
MAKES LIKE HOPE NINETEEN EVEN
WARD WHILE WORKING TO COME UP
WITH FUTURE LEGAL CERTAINTY
THERE ARE EVER CONTROL BUT IT
WOULD BE SO HELPFUL AND WITH IT
A LITTLE MEETING. THE PUBLIC
COMMENT. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBER. OR IN THE
GALLERY. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER OR IN THE GALLERY. ANY
TWEETERS ON THE CHAMBER FLOOR
OR IN THE GALLERY. SEEING NONE
WE WILL MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES
EIGHTEEN ANTI MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
OR ON THE PHONE OR- IN THE
QUEUE. AGAIN THE COMMANDOS ONE
AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. KEYPAD IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN SUPPORT ME PRESS ONE
THEN THEY'RE ALL. WE DO HAVE A
FEW IN Q. AT THIS TIME SIR ONE
MOMENT PLEASE.
OUR FIRST PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT TODAY COMES
FROM LINE FIFTY SEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
THIS IS JANET LOCAL CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
COMMENT FROM LINE FIFTY NINE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE OF THE
OPEN. WONDERFUL MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TO MORNING DAVID WAR
TODAY OR FIRSTTHING CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CHRISTIAN
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES ON
BEHALF OF THE RANGE GROUP. WORK
OF A TALL PRIVATE NONPROFIT
SCHOOLS ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT AB TWENTY THIRTY AND
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO
BRING FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE A COMMENT
FROM LINE FIFTY EIGHT FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHEN I
WORK REMOTELY CAUGHT MAKING A
COLLEGE STUDENT AND I AM IN.
THE THANK YOU. MODERATOR ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. YOU
HAVE A FEW MORE IN Q. NEXT WILL
GO TO LINE TWENTY NINE. TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MELISSA BARTER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA'S UNIQUE MISSION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THIRTY. THANK YOU. FINALLY WE
HAVE LINE SIXTY SIX ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THANK YOU SO
MUCH ASSEMBLY OF THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AVAILABLE
CAROLINE RHEA AND I AM A
STUDENT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
WILL BURKE. AS A PARENT AND ARE
GIVEN THAT HIS OR HER FIFTEEN
YEAR I AM A STRONG SUPPORT FOR
E. TWENTY THIRD. THANK YOU YOU.
THANK YOU MODERATOR AND WILL
ONE AND- MORE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF MEDICARE. NINE NINE
TO GET THE TIME. SO THANK YOU
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE OR ON THE QUEUE. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO THE
WITNESS AT THIS TIME IT'S ONE
AND THEN ZERO IF YOUR POSITION
IN OPPOSITION. NO ONE IN Q. AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU- THANK YOU
AGAIN ANY WITNESSES THAT ARE
CLEANERS. FOR ANY TWEENER SMI
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. NO NO
NOT AT THE TIME SIR THANK YOU
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SEEING NONE TO THE
AUTHOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PROVIDE A CLOSING STATEMENT
THANK YOU MISTER TERRY THAT'S
MY HONOR TO WORK ON BEHALF OF
THE MANY DESERVING STUDENTS TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE ARE ARE
FORGET THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES
OTHERS HAVE BENEFITTED FROM AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. WITH OVER 20% OF OUR
STUDENTS ATTENDING INDEPENDENT
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. I BELIEVE THE
FORMULA WILL ALLOW FOR
PREDICTABILITY. SENSE OF
SOMETHING THAT IS CRUCIAL. AS
WE ALL SEEK WAYS TO BOUNCE BACK
FROM THE DEVASTATION TO OUR
ECONOMY. DO TO COPE WITH
NINETEEN. THIS MEASURE WILL
ASSIST STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. AS A PLAN FOR THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS AND PROVIDES
EQUITY FOR STUDENTS. I DO HAVE
A MOTION FOR THIS BILL. FIRST
AND SECOND MATTER THE- MOTION
BEFORE US IS DO PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BUT
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEDINA HI MEDINA I WILL TELL.
WILL TELL HI ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
HI BLOOM BLOOM HI GABRIEL
GABRIEL HI EARLY. IRWIN HI
KILEY KILEY HI LEVINE LEVINE HI
LO. LO HI PATTERSON. PATTERSON
HI SANTIAGO WEBER WEBER HI
MISTER CHAIR THE VOTE ELEVEN
TWO ZERO PRESENTLY. THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY THE BILL PASSES
YOUR BILL IS OUT- I WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. THE NEXT BILL IN FILE
IN ORDER. TO BE HEARD IS AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTEEN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL WHEN YOU'RE
READY PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TODAY 2% AB TWENTY FOUR
SIXTEEN WHICH WILL REQUIRE
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
CONSIDER HOMELESSNESS AS AN
EXTENUATING CIRCUMSTANCE WHEN
DETERMINING WHETHER A STUDENT
SHOULD LOSE THEIR FINANCIAL AID
FOR FAILURE TO MEET CERTAIN
ACADEMIC BENCHMARKS. UNDER
CURRENT LAW STUDENTS ARE
REQUIRED TO ACHIEVE
SATISFACTORY ACADEMIC PROGRESS
OR SAT TO REMAIN ELIGIBLE FOR
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE. EVERY
YEAR THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS LOSE THEIR FINANCIAL
AID BECAUSE THEY FAIL TO
MAINTAIN SATISFACTORY ACADEMIC
PROGRESS. A STUDENT WHO FALLS
BELOW ESSAY P. MAY FILE AN
APPEAL ASKING TO RETAIN THEIR
FINANCIAL AID BASED ON
EXTENUATING CIRCUMSTANCES. WHAT
MAY BE CONSIDERED EXTENUATING
CIRCUMSTANCES CURRENTLY VARIES
WIDELY FROM CAMPUS TO CAMPUS AS
INDIVIDUAL INSTITUTIONS ARE
PROVIDED WITH SIGNIFICANT
FLEXIBILITY TO DETERMINE WHAT
FACTORS MAY BE CONSIDERED FOR
PURPOSES OF RETAINING FINANCIAL
AID. AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTEEN
WOULD PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO
CALIFORNIA'S INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION BY REQUIRING
THEM TO CONSIDER STAINLESS
STUDENT HOMELESSNESS AS AN
EXTENUATING CIRCUMSTANCE. THIS
CHANGES WARRANTED GIVEN THE
EXTRAORDINARY IMPACT OF
HOMELESSNESS CAN HAVE ON
STUDENT SUCCESS THE ROLE THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMPLAIN
LIFTING STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
OUT OF POVERTY AND THE
MAGNITUDE OF OUR STATE HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. WHICH
IS LIKELY TO BE EXACERBATED BY
THE COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS.
INDEED THIS COMMITTEE HAS
REPEATEDLY HER TESTIMONY ABOUT
THE BROAD AND DEVASTATING
IMPACT OF STUDENT HOMELESSNESS
IN CALIFORNIA. WHICH IMPACTS
NEARLY 20% OF OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND MORE THAN
ONE IN TEN AT CSCO. WE ALSO
KNOW THAT STUDENTS FROM
HISTORICALLY UNDER REPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
HOMELESSNESS IN AN ONGOING
ACCESS TO FINANCIAL AID IS A
CENTRAL FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS
TO REMAIN ENROLLED IN GRADUATE.
IN SHORT AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTEEN
IS A MODEST BUT IMPORTANT
MEASURE THAT WILL MAKE IT
EASIER FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING WITH HOMELESSNESS.
AND ALL OF THE RELATED
CHALLENGES TO REMAIN ENROLLED
ACHIEVE ACADEMIC SUCCESS TO
PULL THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY. WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS LEGISLATION ARE DEBBIE
ROCKER FROM JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH. AND TISSUE
ORTIZ A STUDENT FROM CSU HE
EXPECTS. THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE BOTH. THANK
YOU SIMPLY MEMBER GABRIEL
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR THE FIRST
WITNESS CALLING IN FOR AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTEEN IS DEBBIE
RUPTURE. PROJECT DIRECTOR WITH
THE JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR
YOUTH. AS ROGER PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MY NAME IS DEBBIE
RUSHER AND I'M WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY. IN THE FACE OF COVER
NINETEEN AND THE CONSEQUENT
LOSS OF INCOME FOR MANY COLLEGE
STUDENTS THE RATE OF
HOMELESSNESS AMONG STUDENTS IS
LIKELY TO RISE. EVEN PRIOR TO
THE CRISIS 19% OF STUDENTS A
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND 11% OF
CSU STUDENTS REPORTED
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. 60%
OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
REPORTED HOUSING AND SECURITY.
FOR THE STUDENTS AND THE MANY
MORE LIKE TO FACE SOME OF THIS
IN THE YEARS AHEAD I'M GOING
ACTIONS TO FINANCIALLY
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL TO THEIR
ABILITY TO REMAIN INVOLVED. IN
IT EVERY YEAR THOUSANDS OF THE
STUDENTS LOSE ACCESS TO
FINANCIAL AID BECAUSE THEY FALL
BELOW THE SATISFACTORY ACADEMIC
PROGRESS STANDARDS. MY WORK
WITH COLLEGE CAMPUSES STAFF AND
FACULTY CHARGED WITH SUPPORTING
THE STUDENTS REPORT THE LOSS
FINANCIAL AID IS A MAJOR
BARRIER TO CONTINUED
INVOLVEMENT. ALMOST COLLEGES
OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAL
ACOSTA FINANCIAL AID TO SAP
APPEALS PROCESS FEES VARY
TREMENDOUSLY BY CAMPUS. CULTURE
GIVEN SIGNIFICANT LATITUDE
UNDER FEDERAL REGULATIONS TO
DEFINE THE CRITERIA FOR A
SUCCESSFUL APPEAL BUT MANY DO
NOT TAKE AND DID NOT TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS FLEXIBILITY.
WHEN A STUDENT EXPERIENCES
HOMELESSNESS GRAY IT'S OFTEN
DROP HOWEVER HOMELESSNESS IS
NOT UNIVERSALLY DEFINED BY
COLLEGES IS A SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCE. THE WARRANTS A
STUDENT BEING GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAINTAIN
FINANCIALLY IN ORDER TO REMAIN
ENROLLED AND REGAIN ACADEMIC
STANDING. STILL VERY
HOMELESSNESS SHOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET BACK ON
TRACK RATHER THAN THEIR
EXPERIENCE OF HOMELESSNESS
MEANING THE END OF THEIR
ACADEMIC CAREER. CONTINUED
ACCESS TO FINANCIAL AID IS A
VITAL TOOL TO ALLOW THE
STUDENTS TO REMAIN ENROLLED THE
TROOPS ARE ACADEMIC STANDING.
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTEEN WILL
OFFER STUDENTS WHO EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS THIS OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS ROGER
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR THE
SECOND WITNESS CALLING IN THIS
TO SHIP FORTIES. A STUDENT CAL
STATE EAST BAY. MISS PARTIES
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY
EXPERIENCE WITH YOU TODAY I
HAVE DIRECTED. THE CALL THAT
BEING HOME WITH CAN TAKE ON
SOMEONE'S EDUCATION. AS A CHILD
MY FAMILY SITUATION WAS
UNSTABLE ENTER FOSTER CARE AT
FOUR YEARS OLD REUNITED WITH MY
FAMILY HE- AND THEN REENTER
FOSTER CARE AT TWELVE. WERE YOU
MADE ANTI MEDICATED. EIGHTEEN
AND WORK ON MY OWN. I HIGH
SCHOOL I ROLE AT COUNTY STAY
WITHOUT FAMILY SUPPORT I BECAME
HOMEWORK WITHIN THE YEAR THE
TENDING SCHOOL. I BOUNCED
AROUND TO A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
LIVING SITUATIONS ALTHOUGH
WHILE ATTENDING CLASSES IN
TRYING TO KEEP UP WITH SCHOOL
WORK. EVENTUALLY I WOULD THINK
STEPPED INTO A TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM AND MY GRADES
IMPROVED I TRANSITIONED INTO
THE DORMS. AND THEN MY OWN
APARTMENT. BUT MY INCOME WOULD
BIND UP TO ACCORD THE PARCHMENT
AND I AGAIN FOUND MYSELF HOW
MUCH IMPACT IT WOULD DROP ON
CLASSES. AND I'M REMOTE TELL
FROM THE TELL HOW THIRD WITH
FRIENDS AND EVEN ENDED UP IN A
SHELTER FOR A PERIOD OF TIME-
THE EVENTUALLY ABLE TO FIND
PEOPLE HEALTHY. BUT WHEN I TRY
TO RE ENROLL AT CAL THE SALE
TOLD I COULDN'T GET FINANCIAL
AID BECAUSE A SATISFACTORY
ACADEMIC PROGRESS REQUIREMENTS.
ALTHOUGH MANY GPA WITH THE TWO
POINT SEVEN THE FACT THAT I
HAVE WITHDRAWN FROM CLASSES
WHEN I BECAME HOMELESS. THIS
CALL OKAY WHAT I NEED FOR
FRENCH AID. THERE'S NO WAY THAT
I REPORTED TEN SCHOOL WITHOUT
FINANCIAL AID. NO PROFIT HAS
BEEN VERY CHALLENGING AND SO I
WASN'T ABLE TO ENROLL FOR THIS
SEMESTER. I HOPE TO RETURN NEXT
YEAR AS I HAVE JUST TWENTY FOUR
UNITS LEFT. TO COMPLETE MY
BACHELORS DEGREE. A TWENTY FOUR
SIXTEEN ALL MAKING EASIER FOR
STUDENTS LIKE MICHAEL. BASED
HOMELESSNESS TO GET ON TRACK
REMAIN IN IN NEXT URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MR THIESSEN
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER IN
THE GALLERY. IN SUPPORT. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
BACK OF THE GALLERY. OR ON THE
CHAMBER FLOOR. ANY CLEANERS IN
THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER FLOOR
OR IN THE GALLERY. SEEING NONE
WE WILL MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES
EIGHTY EIGHTY MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES OR SUPPORT.
ON THE PHONE OR ON THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU AGAIN THE COMMAND IS
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS THE BUTTON
THAT THIS TIME THAT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO. WE DO HAVE SEVERAL
IN Q. WOULD BE JUST A MOMENT
PLEASE.
OUR FIRST COMMENT TODAY
COMES FROM LINE SIX ONE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON LITERATURE
MEMBERS- MY NAME'S PARTIAL
CONSTRUCTING THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION BEYOND STRONG
SUPPORT WE APPRECIATE WATER OUT
COULD BRING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION. AND WE ALL HAD
SUPPORTIVE EDWARDS AND
INTENTION. ONE TO USE THEIR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
COMMENT FROM LINE SIXTY SIX
LINE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE GOLDEN ON BEHALF OF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND MARK. THANK YOU. Q. NEXT WE
HAVE A COMMON FROMLINE SIXTY
SEVEN LINE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU THIS
IS- TYLER REGULAR AND THE AFTER
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AFTER THE PRESIDENT WE DO HAVE
A FORMAL POSITION ON THE BILL
AT THIS TIME BUT WE ARE WORKING
TOWARDS A SUPPORT POSITION TO
REALLY APPRECIATE. THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE'LL GO
NEXT THE LINE SIXTY ONE. NINE
SIX ONE LINERS OPEN. MY NAME IS
FIFTY DEGREES BEEN SPEAKING IN
FAVOR OF A THREE TO FOUR ONE
SIX I GRADUATED HIGH SCHOOL IN
RANCHO CUCAMONGA AND AM
CURRENTLY A SECOND YEAR AT THE
STATE UNIVERSITY. I WAS
HOMELESS MY ENTIRE HIGH SCHOOL
CAREER WITH MY FAMILY THE
HOMELESS WELL I HAVE NOTHING TO
FALL BACK ON- MY FAMILY I NEED
TO. NINETY I NEED TO REMIND THE
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE THAT
WE'RE JUST DOING THE ME TOO AND
RIGHT NOW AND SO I'M JUST
ASKING FOR YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
TO JUST YOUR NAME AND WHO
YOU'RE WITH. AND THE POSITION
ON THE BILL. THREE PEOPLE
THINGS PLEASE. AND MODERATOR IF
THAT CALLER IS NO LONGER ON THE
LINE WILL MOVE TO THE NEXT
CALLER AND JUST REMIND
WITNESSED HERE THE RIDGES IN
OUR NAME THE ORGANIZATION WITH
AND THE POSITION ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU. IT WILL MOVE TO LINE
SIX FOUR NINE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME CAN THE
BOND THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS AND WE ARE IN
DAVID A. B. TWO FOUR ONE SIX.
THANK YOU. NINE SIX FIVE SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SCHMIDT
CHAIRMAN MANAGING REPRESENTED
FOUND THEY EVER BRING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT. OR THANK YOU.
FIND SIXTY THREE SIX THREE YOUR
LINE OF OPEN. HELLO HELLO MY
NAME IS THE THEORY IN OUR
SPEAKING A CLEAVER AB TWO FOUR
ONE SIX I'M A FIRST YEAR
STUDENT AT UCLA NINE AND A PART
OF SCHOOL HEALTH CONNECTION.
THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY TWO SIX
TWO YOUR LINE OF THE- MR KAREN
MEMBER TOLD ME OF POLICE SHOT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO WILL GO TO LINE SIX NINE
SIX NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS MARTY I'M JUST
CALLING AS A STUDENT AT
SACRAMENTO STATE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU. FIND
ONLINE SUPPORT WILL BE FROM
SEVENTY SEVEN ZERO YOUR LINE OF
THE- GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BRENDA THAT MEDINA GO ALONG-
I'M NOT THE PUBLIC COUNSEL ARE
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FOUR SIX. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MODERATOR AND WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE OR
IN THE QUEUE. THEIR ARGUMENT
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. NONE
IN Q. AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
ANY WITNESSES WHO ARE TWEETERS
ON THE PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE.
ANYONE HOLDING THAT POSITION
MAY ALSO PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. NO ONE IN Q. PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL WOULD YOU LIKE TO GIVE
A CLOSING STATEMENT. THE
TESTIMONY FROM THE WITNESS SAYS
AND THE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
DRIVE A- AND AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIVER YOU DID- EXCEPT THE-
AMENDMENTS CORRECT YES MISTER.
ALL RIGHT SO THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS IS OUTLINED ON PAGE
FOUR OF THE ANALYSIS
ADDITIONALLY THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD. I
FEEL I FEAR THAT EVEN MORE
COLLEGE STUDENTS WILL BECOME
HOMELESS DUE TO THE IMPACT OF
CODE NINETEEN. THIS MEASURE
WILL PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
MEANS ENSURING HOMELESS
STUDENTS WHOSE ACADEMIC SUFFER
BECAUSE OF THEIR STATUS WILL
HAVE THE POSSIBILITY OF
MAINTAINING THEIR FINANCIAL AID.
DUE TO THIS CIRCUMSTANCE. HAD A
FIRST AND A SECOND THE MOTION
BEFORE US IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. SECRETARY VIEW
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE WILL
TELL. VOEPEL HI ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI BLOOM BLOOM HI
GABRIEL GABRIEL HI IRWIN. IRWIN
HI KILEY KILEY LEVINE LEVINE HI
LO LO HI PATTERSON. PATTERSON
HI SANTIAGO WEBER. WEBER HI
MISTER CHAIR THE CURRENT VOTE
IS ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN ZERO YOUR
BILL IS OUT LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NOW GOING
ONTO AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY TWO
FILE ITEM NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
Là M<c.cyan> WHEN YOU ARE READY</c>
PLEASE PERCY. YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY
TWO REQUIRED THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITIES
AND THE REQUEST FOR YOU SEE TO
INDIVIDUALLY CREATE SEGMENT WHY
ONLINE TRAINING PROGRAM
RELATING TO AND DOCUMENTED
STUDENT DOCTOR RECIPIENTS AND
AB FIVE FORTY STUDENTS. THE
ONLINE TRAINING WOULD BE
REQUIRED FOR CAMPUS
ADMINISTRATORS. OF THEIR
RESPECTIVE SEGMENTS TO COMPLETE
ANNUALLY AND IT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR ANY EMPLOYEE OF
THE UNIVERSITY TO PARTICIPATE
CURRENTLY ESTIMATES FIND THAT
BETWEEN SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND AND
EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND AND
DOCUMENTED STUDENTS ARE IN
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM.
IN CALIFORIA ACROSS THE THREE
SYSTEMS OF HIGHER EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
FACING FEAR AND UNCERTAINTY AS
THEY CONTINUE THEIR HIGHER
EDUCATION JOURNEY. IN ADDITION
CALIFORNIA IS HOME 229% OF OUR
NATION'S DOCKET RECIPIENT. AND
THEY ARE CURRENTLY FACING
UNCERTAINTY AT THE US SUPREME
COURT DECIDES THERE. HIGHER
EDUCATION IS A DIFFICULT
JOURNEY TO NAVIGATE ON ITS OWN
WITHOUT ANY ADDITIONAL
STRESSORS. AND THIS COMPLEX
LANDSCAPE CAN BE DIFFICULT TO
NAVIGATE WHEN CAMPUS DECISION
DECISION MAKERS DO NOT FULLY
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUES THERE
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS ARE
FACING. THIS BILL FILL THE GAP
THAT OFTEN. MOVED CAMPUS
ADMINISTRATORS HAVE NGUYEN
UNDERSTANDING THE DIFFERENCES
ARE OVERLAP BETWEEN
UNDOCUMENTED AB FIVE FORTY AND
DOCTOR STUDENTS. ALL DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES CALIFORNIA HAS
EMBRACED UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
AND HAS AN ACTIVE MEASURES THAT
ALLOW THEM TO HAVE ACCESS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION AND CONTRIBUTE
TO THE ECONOMY. I HOPE THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE THAT TODAY. ON THE
PHONE WE HAVE REYES TANK VICE
PRESIDENT OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE. STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND
EVELYN PETTUS SAN JOSE STATE
AND DOCU SPARTAN RESOURCE
CENTER STUDENT ASSISTANCE. MON
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY MODERATOR THE
FIRST LEAD WITNESS CALLING IN
FOR AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY TWO
IS GRACE PAN VICE PRESIDENT FOR
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR THE CAL
STATE STUDENT ASSOIATION MISS
PANG PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. HI EVERYONE MY NAME IS
GREAT HANG IN A THIRD YEAR
STUDENT CALLING IN TODAY AS- OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR THE
COUNTY STUDENT ASSOCIATION. YES
YOU DO HAVE TO SPONSOR AB
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY Q. AND WE
CALLED THE LEADERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATURE ACTON THE
URGENCY AND NEED FOR THIS BILL.
THE TRAINING WILL INCLUDE
CRITICAL POLICY UPDATE THE
AMPLIFIED ELIGIBLE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE FOR THE STUDENTS. IT
WOULD ALSO TRAIN CAMPUS LEADERS
ON DIFFERENT IMMIGRATION
STATUS. FOR EXAMPLE DR AB FIVE
FORTY AND BEING UNDOCUMENTED
DIFFERENT TACTICS HAVE BEEN
USED INTERCHANGEABLY BIKE
INSTITUTIONAL LEADERSHIP EVEN
THOUGH THE DIFFERENT
CHALLENGES. YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW
HARD FOR THE LACK OF A WHERE
YOU CAN BE WHEN YOU GO DOWN TO
THE UNIVERSITY DIRECTORY.
ADVOCACY PRIORITY FUNDING
DECISIONS INTERACTIONS WITH
STUDENTS AND PROVIDING CRUCIAL
THIRD IT'S LIKE FINANCIAL LEGAL.
AND THE EIGHT. AFTER LAND AND
WATER CALL OF IMPACT YOU DID
CURRENTLY THE WHITE TREE BUT
ANY OF THE FOR NOW BOB YEAR I
IT'S GET THREE THANK. THANK YOU
ALL CREATED THEIR OWN ABOUT
TRAINING MAKING A BILL INCLUDES
SIMPLE AND LOW COST I THINK
THEM JEFF BEFORE NOT ON FOR
REST OF THE CAMPUS. AND
CHANCELLOR OUR PRESIDENT OFFICE
I. OWNERS TO GRADUATE AND WE
ARE ASKING THAT THEY BE. AND
I'M PRESIDENT AND CHALLENGING.
WE MUST BUILDING AND PATHETIC
IN FOR COMMUNITY OF. MANDATED
ONLY. IT IS LONG WILL. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR KIND WITH YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND WE HOPE TO SEE A
TWO NINE TWO THERE THANK YOU.
THANK MISS BANK MODERATOR THIS
LEAD WITH CALLING IN HIS EVELYN
PAT IS A STUDENT FROM SAN JOSE
STATE UNIVERSITY. AS BAD AS
WHEN YOU ARE READY. HELLO
TERMINATE THEM MY NAME IS EVERY
BIT AS AND I AM A CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT DEVELOPMENT MAJOR
SHOOTING AT EIGHT EIGHT.
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS I HAVE
EXPERIENCE FIRST HAND THE BEAR
YEARS ONE BASIS TO REACH HIGHER
EDUCATION. ACROSS THE STATE YOU
DON'T HAVE BEEN LIVING IN FEAR
AND UNCERTAINTY AT THE WORK TO
ATTAIN THEIR DEGREES. MANY
STUDENTS CONTEMPLATE INNOVATION
ROLE OR CONTINUE THEIR
INVESTMENT IF PROTECTION FROM
DEPORTATION OR FINANCIAL
SECURITY IS AT RISK. NOT I AM
CURRENTLY WORKING AT END DOCTOR
TO HEAR ME TO CENTER AYE AYES
GQ I WORK DIRECTLY WITH
STUDENTS WHO ARE IMPACTED BY
THE STATE ADVERSITY. IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR ADMIN TO
UNDERSTAND THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES FACING STUDENTS.
WITH THE PENDING DOCTOR
POSITION AND CURRENT PANDEMIC.
WHICH HAD WIDENED EXISTING GAP.
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT FOR
ADMINISTRATORS TO RECOGNIZE THE
ROLE AND RESPONSIBILITY IN
CLOSING THOSE GAPS.
PRIORITIZING THE RETENTION AND
WELLNESS OF ALL AND DOCUMENTS
STUDENT. NO YOU'RE RIGHT
TRAINING OPEN DON'T KNOW
MANDATORY TO VARIOUS GROUPS ON
CAMPUS. NOT EVERYONE AT THE
DECISION MAKING TABLE
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT THEY HAVE
ON THE LIKELY CAUSE AN
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE KENTUCKY
STUDENTS. STUDENTS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS PART FOR YOU
WITH THEIR UNIVERSITIES. YOU
HAVE ENTERED AND COORDINATORS
ACROSS THE STATE TO SUPPORT OUR
VULNERABLE HIGH NEED A DOCTOR.
WE NOW SEE COORDINATORS WHO
WORK AT FULL CAPACITY TO CREATE
AND HOST TRAINING MAKING IT
HARDER FOR US TO STIR STUDENT
ATHLETES AND- I HAVE NO DOUBT
THAT INCOMING A DOCU
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS. AND THE
FUTURE WILL CONTINUE TO BE
UNPREDICTABLE PRESSURES AND
OPTICAL. HOWEVER IT SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO ACCEPT OR WORRY ABOUT
THE CAMPUS LEADERS NOT BEING.
EQUIPPED WITH THE TIMELY
INFORMATION AND TRAINING
NEEDED. TO SERVICE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME I HOPE AB TWENTY
NINE FOR ME TO CAN PASS TODAY
AND BE SIGNED UP CALIFORNIA LAW
FOR THE GENERATIONS OF STUDENTS
HAD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS
BETTERS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBER OR IN THE
GALLERY. ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER OR IN THE GALLERY. ANY
WITNESSES THAT ARE TWEETERS IN
THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER IN THE
GALLERY SCENE NINE WE WILL MOVE.
EIGHTY ANTI MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE. FOR
THOSE THAT ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE
SEVERAL JUST A MOMENT. AGO
FIRST IN LINE SIX ONE SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON-
THIS IS POSSIBLE SHALL WE WITH
THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT LOCAL PER LINE
SEVENTY FIVE LINE SEVEN FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MEDINA
MEMBER DAVID BALLOT HAWKINS
WITH THAT THE ISSUE FOR YOU
BEING IN OFFERING STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT WE
HAVE A COMMON FROM LINE SEVENTY
ONE SEVEN ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MR TURN MEMBERS SOVIET PHILLIES
SHANTI HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE SEVENTY SIX SEVEN SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NOBODY STUDENT
AT SACRAMENTO STATE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY TWO. THANK YOU. LINE
SEVEN FOUR SEVENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MEMBERS STOPPING TWENTY
MEMBERS THE LIST WE I AM I
THANK YOU IN AND THEN HE HAS TO
SAY BOARD MEMBER AND I'M STRONG
SUPPORTER. THANK YOU. LINE
SIXTY FOUR SIX FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT THERE WITH A
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS AND WE ARE IN STRONG.
THANK YOU. LINE SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN SEVEN THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
THE BY THE MINUTE THAT I MEAN
POLICY IN TURN WOULD CHIRLA THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE SEVENTY TWO
SEVEN TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU THIS IS MERRY MORRELL
WITH THAT HE HE IF YOU WE JUST
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE OSCAR IN THE
SPONSORING CLEAR FINE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE SUPPORT THE
STUDENTS AND WE SUPPORT THE
GOAL OF AN THAT THEY'LL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE FORTY FOUR
AIRLINE US OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS JAKE PARTNER ON BEHALF
OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NO
FOR THE LINE CAN SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR
AND WITNESSES AND SUPPORT ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ON THE PHONE OR IN
THE QUEUE. WE DO HAVE TO IN Q.
THOUGH AT THEY MAY BE IN
SUPPORT STILL ONE MOMENT SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN DO
YOU HAVE A POSITION. YES I DID
MANAGE VIçT. REPRESENT PANEL
THEY EVER BRING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT ONE OF THANK THE
LEADERSHIP OF A NOMINALLY MALL
IT'S BEEN NINETEEN YEARS FROM
THE FIRST PASSAGE OF AB FIVE
EIGHT AGAIN I NEED TO REMIND I
NEED TO REMIND THE WITH THIS IS
ON THE PHONE THAT IT'S JUST
YOUR NAME THE GROUP YOU'RE WITH
AND THE POSITION ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO THE NEXT
WITNESS. AND FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS MY VALLEY KINCAID WITH
PUBLIC ADVOCATE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND AGAIN
IF THERE'S ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
NOT AT THIS TIME. MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES WHO ARE
TWEETERS ON THE PHONE OR IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU IF THERE ARE
ANY WINNERS- IF YOUR POSITION
IS A TWEENER PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN THEY'RE ALL. NO ONE IN
Q. AT THE TIME PLEASE CONTINUE.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER IF YOU'D
LIKE TO MAKE A CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A- THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD THIS BILL
FOR. KNOWING THE DOCTOR COULD
GO AWAY IN SHORT ORDER ORDER.
AND DUE TO THE ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES THAT UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS FACE DUE TO COVERT
NINETEEN FACULTY AND STAFF
INCLUDING ADMINISTRATORS NEED
TO RECEIVE SPECIFIC TRAINING.
FOR ARE UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
PLEASE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THE COMMENTS ON PAGE
FOUR. OF THE ANALYSIS TO HAVE A
MOTION. OF THE FIRST AND SECOND.
THE MOTION BEFORE US IS DO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEDINA HI MEDINA I WILL TELL.
VOEPEL NOT VOTING ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI LOU. BLOOM HI
GABRIEL GABRIEL HI IRWIN IRWIN
HI KILEY. KILEY NO LEVINE
LEVINE HI LO LO HI PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO WEBER WEBER HI. MISTER
CHAIR THE CURRENT VOTE IS EIGHT
ONE. YOUR BILL IS OUT WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU. THE NEXT
BILL IN FILE ORDERED TO BE
HEARD IS AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
MISTER MCCARTY WHEN YOU ARE
READY THESE PER SE. RIGHT THERE
OKAY WELCOME. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- MEMBERS TO
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT THIS
BILL THIS BILL IS ABOUT HELP
BEING RE INTEGRATE. INDIVIDUALS
INVOLVED IN OUR CRIMINAL%
JUSTICE SYSTEM IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SEGMENT BACK IN SOCIETY
YOU KNOW THE PAST FEW YEARS
WE'VE HLP SUPPORT THE CSU
PROGRAM PROJECT REBOUND. AS
WELL AS A SCHOLARS PROGRAM AT
THE UC BUT DON'T HAVE AN EFFORT
AT OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. A STRUCTURED AFTER
MANY CAN BE CALLED IS CURRENTLY
DO THIS AND HELPING IN ROLE
STUDENTS WHILE THEY'RE
INCARCERATED HELP THEM. SUCCEED
ONCE THEY- ARE PAROLED IT CAN
ENTER AS STUDENTS AT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM WE
KNOW THAT WE'RE TAKING GREAT
STATE GREAT- GREAT- STRIDES IN
OUR STATE TO HELP. REINTEGRATE
BACK IN SOCIETY. THAT COLLEGE.
IS ONE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS
THAT CAN DO. SO WE ARE WORKING
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO
ESTABLISH THIS RISING SCHOLARS
PROGRAM. WITHIN UP TO FIFTY
CAMPUSES THROUGHOUT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICABLE SYSTEM-
AS YOU KNOW AN INTIMATELY
INVOLVED IN THE BUDGET PROCESS
AND ALL BODIES THINGS- COST
MONEY AS WELL SO WE'RE WORKING
WITH- THE CHANCES OFFICE AND-
OUR- BUDGET TEAM TO MAKE SURE
WE INTEGRATE. THESE PROGRAMS
INTO THE BUDGET AS WE DISCUSSED
AT THIS SPRING SUMMER- WITH
THAT ASK YOU RIGHT NOT TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MANY
MEMBER MCCARTY THE FIRST LEAD
WITNESS IS TAMI LUNA A STUDENT
AT SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE YOU
WILL BE PROVIDING TESTIMONY VIA
THE CAPITAL WITNESS. VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM. MR DELUDE UP
PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY WHEN YOU ARE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY FOR
ALLOWING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY ONE. SO
LAST YEAR I WAS RELEASED AFTER
NEARLY TWO AND A HALF DECADES
IN PRISON. I WAS HOPING TO FIND
A JOB ON MY RELEASE BUT QUICKLY
FOUND OUT THAT JOB EXPERIENCE
TRUMPS LIFE EXPERIENCE. WITH NO
REAL EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES I
TURNED TO WHAT I KNOW BEST.
COLLEGE OVER THE LAST SIX YEARS
I'VE EARNED TO ASSOCIATE
DEGREES WHILE INCARCERATED.
AFTER LEARNING ABOUT SEX CITIES
REEMERGENCE SCHOLARS PROGRAM I
TOOK ADVANTAGE OF THEIR HELP IN
A ROLLED IN THE FALL SEMESTER
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. I CANNOT
TELL YOU HOW COURT IS PROGRAM
IS BEEN FOR ME. I WAS LOST AND
NEEDED GUIDANCE MANY OF THE
PARTICIPANTS IN THE PARK IN THE
PROGRAM HAD UNDERSTOOD MY NEEDS
AND QUICKLY ASSISTED ME. I
ENROLLED IN THE SEMESTER THE
LAST MINUTE. TO ENSURE THAT I
HAD MY FINANCIAL AID TAKEN CARE
OF AND THEY ALSO ASSISTED ME IN
DECIDING ON MY COMMUNICATIONS
MY MAJOR. I'M NOT NEARLY
FINISHED WITH YET ANOTHER
ASSOCIATES DEGREE BUT SEEKING
TO TRANSFER TO A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY SO. I AM NOT AN
EXCEPTION BUT JUST ONE OF
THOUSANDS YES TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE PROGRAM EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES INSIDE. HIGHER
EDUCATION IS NOT TYPICALLY
AVAILABLE TOO MANY OF THOSE WHO
FIND THEMSELVES IN PRISON. NOT
NEEDED A PROGRAM LIKE RISING
SCHOLARS TO HELP ME REALIZE MY
POTENTIAL. OUT HERE IN THE
COMMUNITY. THIS BILL WILL
ASSIST THOSE RETURNING TO
SOCIETY TO CONTINUE IN THE
DIRECTION OF REHABILITATION AND
CLOSE THE DOOR. A BACK TO
PRISON GOOD. PLEASE VOTE
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY ONCE PASSAGE THANK YOU
AGAIN. THANK YOU MISTER DELUNA
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. EIGHTEEN
ANTI MODERATOR THIS SECOND LEAD
WITNESS SHOULD BE ON THE LINE
REBECCA SOBRE SENIOR DIRECTOR
OF THE RISING SCHOLARS PROGRAM
AT THE FOUNDATION FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
MISS SOBRE PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. Q. AND GOOD
AFTERNOON AT THIS IS REBECCA
CLOVER AT THE SENIOR DIRECTOR
OF WRITINGS DOLLARS THE
FOUNDATION FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE WORK WITH
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
SUPPORTING THE COLLEGES DURING
YOU CURSOR ON THE CURSOR TO
KEEP THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MCCARTY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS A CRITICAL
ISSUE EVEN NOW ESPECIALLY EVEN
NOW IT'S CRITICAL FOR THE STATE
AND THE WHOLE WE KNOW. THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE EDUCATION.
THE TARGET WILL THE THERE WILL
BE THERE. THE ONLY MAYOREDLEE I
THE PHONE WE KNOW THAT. YOU ARE
ABLE TO ADD IT DON'T GO BACK TO
PRESENT TO THE NOTING. WE HAVE
A CRITICAL FOR COLLEGES THE
WORKING. THE HOW MANY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES EVEN FIVE YEARS
WURSTER. YOU KNOW IN FACE TO
FACE IMPRISONED HAD A HANDFUL
FIVE MAYBE A PROGRAMS ON CAMPUS
WE NOW HAVE SIX OR SEVEN
THOUSAND FACE TO FACE STUDENTS
IN PRESENT WE KNOW AT LEAST
THIRTY COLLEGES ARE SUPPORTING
ON CAMPUS. THIS IS CALIFORNIA
INNOVATION AT ITS BEST THIS IS
THE STATE CALLING ON ITS
RESOURCES CAN. YOU THREE FOR
EVERYONE. BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY
KNOW THAT THIS IS. HE THESE ARE
SOME OF THE MOST STUDENTS IN
OUR- AND THESE ARE THE LAST YOU
CAN THE LAST ONE FOR WHICH IT
WAS OKAY TO SAY IF CHEATING IS
GOOD ENOUGH FOR YOU FOR A VERY
LONG TIME. AND AT THE STATE WE
KNOW WE CAN DO BETTER THAN THAT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM WE
KNOW THAT WE ARE READY TO
RECEIVE THE STUDENT. REPORTER
AND THE STUDENTS. BUT THEY'RE
NOT GOTTEN AND WE ALL KNOW THAT
THE STATE YOU CAUGHT EVERYONE'S
LOOKING DIFFERENT COUNTY TIMES
AHEAD IF THERE'S SO MUCH MORE
THAT WE HOPE TO DO FOR THE
STUDENTS IN THE FUTURE. FOR NOW
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
THE STUDENTS KNOW THAT WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT A COMMITMENT TO
EQUITY AN OPPORTUNITY THAT WE
ME THAT. THAT LEAST NOT FOR THE
BUT WE'RE HERE FOR THE- SUPPORT
THAT SO WITH THAT THANK OU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FIGURE OFF THE
SHIP THANK YOU TO COMMITTEE AND
WE ASK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
AB TWENTY TWO FORTY. THANK YOU
MISTER OVER WE MOVED THE PUBLIC
COMMENT ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER OR IN THE GALLERY. ANY
WHICH- OPPOSITION IN THE BACK
OF THE CHAMBER IN THE GALLERY.
ANY CLEANERS AND THE CHAMBER IN
THE GALLERY. SCENE NINE WILL
MOVE TO THE PHONES EIGHTEEN P.
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE OR ON THE QUEUE. PART OF
THIS PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. JUST A MOMENT WE DO HAVE
A FEW IN Q. ONE AND THEN ZERO.
GO TO LINE AT ONE LINE EIGHT
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I GET ORIGINALLY SAC
STATE DIDN'T I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AS WELL. THANK YOU.
THANKS LOCAL TO LINE FORTY FOUR
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
ANYMORE DEAL PROGRAM ANALYST AT
THE CAMPAIGN FOR CALLS
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. FOR THE LINE SEVEN
NINE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. KATELYN OUR COMMUNITY
TURNING AT THE CENTER AND WE
PROTECT ITSELF. THANK YOU. AND
FINALLY WILL GO TO LINE EIGHTY
EIGHT ZERO LINE OF THE. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS JEFF NOR I'M AN
ENGLISH PROFESSOR SACRAMENTO
CITY COLLEGE CURRENTLY TEACHES
THAT ARE RE EMERGING SCHOLARS
PROGRAM. AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY ONE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NO FURTHER LINE
CAN QUEUE WHEN SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU FOR THE-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE OR ON THE QUEUE. FOR
THOSE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. NO
SUCH LINING Q. AT THIS TIME
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU
MODERATOR ANY WITNESSES WHO ARE
TWEETERS ON THE PHONE OR IN THE
QUEUE. YOUR POSITION AS TWEENER
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
WE DO HAVE ALL A LINE IN THIS
POSITION ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
LINE EIGHTY TWO ONE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I CAMPER LIKE THE
NATIONAL PORK. AB TWENTY FIFTY
FOUR. AND YOUR POSITION. THANK
YOU THE OTHER TWO WINNERS ON
THE PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE. NOT
AT THIS TIME SIR THANK YOU. TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SCENE NINE MISTER
MCCARTY WOULD YOU LIKE TO GIVE
A CLOSING STATEMENT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION ASK THE
ARRIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER
MCCARTY AND THANK YOU FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL. RISING
SCHOLARS IS AN APPROPRIATE NAME
I THINK CONSIDERING HOW MANY
JUST AS INVOLVED STUDENTS HAVE
FOUND SUCCESS PARTICIPATING IN
OUR EXISTING PROGRAMS. OF
HIGHER EDUCATION IS IN POWER
ONE OF THE GREAT EQUALIZERS AND
I'VE SOCIETY YOUR BILL WILL
GIVE MORE PEOPLE WHO NEED THESE
OPPORTUNITIES A CHANCE TO EARN
AN EDUCATION AND IN RETURN IS
TO CONTRIBUTE. TO THE GREAT
TASK TAPESTRY IT IS CALIFORNIA.
PROMOTE I HAVE AND A SECOND
MADAM SECRETARY THE MOTION IS
DO PASSED IN THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE IF YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE MOTION IS DO YOU
PASSED THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEDINA AYE MEDINA I
WILL TELL VOEPEL FROM THE LEFT
ARAMBULA HI BLOOM. BLUE APRIL
GIVEN BY IRWIN- IRWIN AYE KILEY
KILEY HI LEVINE LEVINE I LOW
LOW I PATTERSON PATTERSON ON A
SANTIAGO WEBER WEBER HI MISTER
CHAIR THE CURRENT VOTE IS THE
PLAN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT. THE
SECOND AND I'LL LEAVE THE ARE
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THE SECOND
TO THE LAST BILL TO BE HEARD
TODAY IS A. B. THIRTY ONE
THIRTY SEVEN FILE ITEM FOR ME
BY ASSEMBLY. NOW WHEN YOU'RE
READY. MISTER CHAIR AND
CALLING. MEMBERS TODAY I
PRESENT TO YOU A. B. THIRTY ONE
THIRTY SEVEN WITH ADDICTS GOD
FOR ACTIVE DUTY AND RESERVE
MILITARY PER. IN THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE THIS PROGRAM IS A
GERMAN GRANT CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO
ARE ACTIVE DUTY RESERVISTS IN
THE U. S. ARMED FORCES OR THIS
STATE HARD. WITH ALL PROMISES
PROGRAM IF IT ALL TO ACTIVE
DUTY AND RETURNED TO THE
PROGRAM ONCE A RETURN WITHOUT.
KNOWLEDGE ABILITY FOR THE FEE
WAIVER OR ANY OTHER BENEFITS
OFFERED AND ALLOWS ACTIVE AND
RESERVISTS MILITARY PERSONNEL.
RETAILER BELOW THE SURFACE
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
PROMISE PRO. ACTIVE TERM HARM
ME FROM. THE CALIFORNIA ARMY
NATIONAL GUARD WITHIN THE
DEFINITION OF ARMED FORCES TO
ENSURE BOTH THE CALIFORNIA ARMY
HARD. THE CALIFORNIA AIR
NATIONAL GUARD ARE INCLUDED IN
THE DEATH AND- COLLEAGUES WITH
MEMBER THE NOT. THEY'RE NOT
OPTIONAL IT'S A BLANK CHECK THE
MEMBERS ARE REQUIRED TO REPORT
WHEN ORDERED AND HAVE NO
KNOWLEDGE ON WHEN THEY'LL- WITH
THE RECENT OUTBREAK A. THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED SERVICE MEMBERS
BEING DEPLOYED TO ASSIST
MEMBERS OUR COMMUNITY IF THERE
ARE ANY OF THOSE SERVICE
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN RULED IN A
CCC PROMISE PROGRAM IT FELT IT
NECESSARY TO WITHDRAW FROM
SCHOOL ORDER TO SEND IT THEY
WOULD LOSE THEIR PROM LA. MOVIE
ALTHOUGH WITH I PROTECTION FOR
THOSE EARLY DEPLOYED WORLD
ORDERS WILL HELPED TO GREG. AND
NO. OVER SO BAKER PRO IN HEALTH
MANY MEMBERS SHOULD STATE OF A-
SUCH THIS EVER HAPPENING. UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW THERE ARE SO
WILL PROTECTION FOR MILITARY
MEMBERS TO ENSURE THEY ARE ABLE.
BE THERE AT WITH BEING. THIS
BILL WOULD ITS PROTECT IS TO
THE FOR. INSURES THAT NONE OF A
WOMEN AND MEN YOU KNOW REPAIR
FOR SERVING COUNTRY OR STATE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MEMBER
VOTE. EIGHTEEN ANTI MATTER THE
ARE NO LEAD WITNESS TO BE HEARD.
ON THIS BY. SO WE'LL NOW MOVE
TO PAY CAR. ANY WITNESSES AND-
IN THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER OR
IN THE GALLERY. ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION IN THE BACK OF
THE CHAMBER OR IN THE GALLERY.
ANY TWEENER IS IN THE BACK OF
THE CHAMBER IN THE GALLERY. SEE
NONE WILL MOVE ON TO THE PHONE
LINE. AT AND T. MODERATOR THERE
ANY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE. WE
DO HAVE ONE IT'S LINE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HEARING NO
RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT LINE IT COMES FROM THE
LINE EIGHTY NINE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE SPEAK. THAT
MANN ON BEHALF OF THE FACULTY.
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN COURT. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE GO TO THE LINE EIGHTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GO AHEAD
NINE EIGHTY TWO. MY AGENT
CAPTAIN I SUPPORT AB TWENTY
FIFTY FOUR. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
NO OTHER LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
MODERATOR AND WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE OR
IN THE QUEUE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. WE HAVE NONE IN Q. THANK
YOU MODERATOR ANY WITNESSES WHO
ARE TWEETERS. ON THE PHONE OR
IN ONCE AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONE MOMENT WE DO HAVE ONE.
LINE FORTY THREE WE'RE OPEN IN
YOUR LINE NOW YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI OUR MONTROSE HAVE SORRY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CHECK HIS
OFFICE WELL WE CANNOT HAVE AN
OFFICIAL FOR THE TODAY ARE. OF
THE OFFICE THE TO CORNER THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ANY ANY OTHER TO.
MODERATOR I DO HAVE ONE CONCERN
THE LINE OF NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IN ONE PERFECT THE
ACTION REQUIRED ON BEHALF TO
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION CAN YOUR
TO SEE SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER WINNERS ARE ONE MORE THAT
IS BUREAU WE HAVE ONE MORE
THAT'S GOOD OF COME FROM THE
LINE OF EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME AN EXACT. OR AB TWENTY
FIFTY. THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
OTHERS IN Q. THANK YOU
MODERATOR GOING UNDER THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SCENE NINE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VOEPEL WOULD YOU LIKE TO
GIVE A CLOSING STATE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ROCK. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS VOEPEL FOR
INTRODUCING THIS LEGISLATION
AND FOR WORKING SO DILIGENTLY
WITH MY STAFF TO EXPAND THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL TO INCLUDE
ALL SERVICE MEMBERS WITH THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT 24% OF THE
RESERVE AND NATIONAL GUARD. IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ETHNIC MIGHT BE
THIS BILL SERVES AS AN
EQUITABLESTEP IN ENSURING THAT
ALL MEMBERS OF THE ARM SO
FORCES HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
CONTINUE TO SERVE AND OBTAIN A
QUALITY EDUCATION THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY KERR IS
WITHOUT. LOSING OR THE- OF
LOSING TUITION WAIVERS DO I
HAVE A MOTION. OF A MOTION AND
A SECOND THE MOTION BEFORE US
IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEDINA I MEDINA HI
FULL TELL VOEPEL HI ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA HI BLOOM BLOOM HI
GABRIEL. GABRIEL HI IRWIN IRWIN
KILEY KILEY AYE LEVINE LEVINE I
LOW. LITTLE HI PATRICK.
PATTERSON HI. SANTIAGO I WEBER
WEBER I MISTER CHAIR THE VOTE
IS TWELVE ZERO TWELVE ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT. AND WE NEED TO
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR- ABSENT
MEMBERS SINCE WE'VE A LAW FOR
THE LAST BILL I WILL BE
PRESENTING AND I WILL BE HANDED
THE GAVEL TO OUR VICE CHAIR.
LESS BILL TODAY IS AB NINETEEN
THIRTY FILE ITEM TWELVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA. PLEASE
PROCEED WHENEVER YOU ARE READY
MISTER CHAIR SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
TODAY I PRESENT AB. NINETEEN
THIRTY. AB NINETEEN THIRTY WILL
INCREASE THE OVERSIGHT A PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY'S ADMISSION AND
ELIGIBILITY POLICIES TO ENSURE
THE POLICY CHANGES ARE
EQUITABLE AND DO NOT HAVE
NEGATIVE. OR AN INTENDED IMPACT
ON UNDER REPRESENTED STUDENT
POPULATIONS. LAST YEAR THE
CALIFORNIASTATE UNIVERSITY
PROPOSED A NEW QUANTITATIVE
REASONING ADMISSIONS
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS FOR
FRESHMAN APPLICANTS. THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD REQUIRE FUTURE
INCOMING FRESHMEN AT THE CSU TO
COMPLETE AN ADDITIONAL YEAR OF
QUANTITATIVE REASONING. THE
LEGISLATURE VOICE MANY CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL AND THE
IMPACT THAT IT COULD HAVE ON
UNDER REPRESENTED STUDENTS.
WELL THE CSU ULTIMATELY DECIDED
TO DELAY THE VOTE ON THIS
PROPOSAL AND TOOK FURTHER STEPS
TO EVALUATE ITS IMPACT THE
STATE NEEDS TO DEVELOP A CLEAR
AND TRANSPARENT PROCESS FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
TO FOLLOW. WHEN CONSIDERING THE
ADOPTION OF NEW ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS. FOR PROPOSALS
WITH THE STAKES IS HIGH IS THIS
MORE TIME AND EVALUATION IS
NEEDED PRIOR TO REACHING A
DECISION. AB NINETEEN THIRTY
WILL ENSURE THAT THE MISSION OF
THE ELIGIBILITY POLICIES ARE
MORE TRANSPARENT. HAVE PROPER
OVERSIGHT AND IMPACT
ASSESSMENTS INCLUDE COORDINATED
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS WITH
PUBLIC ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY
EDUCATION SYSTEMS WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO BUILD UPON OUR GOOD
WORK AND ENSURE THAT OUR PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES REMAIN ENGINES OF
ECONOMIC MOBILITY FOR
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS AND
NOT INCREASE BARRIERS TO ACCESS
TO ACCESS. AB NINETEEN THIRTY
IS AN IMPORTANT OVERSIGHT
NECESSARY TO ENSURING AN
EQUITABLE AND FAIR ADMISSIONS
PROCESS ON THE PHONE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IS MICHELLE SEEK.
PRESIDENT OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY AND MANY
RODRIGUEZ OF THE EDUCATION
CROSS WEST. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA MODERATOR TO
FIRST LEAD WITNESS CALLING IN
FOR A BI NINETEEN THIRTY IS
MICHELLE'S ACQUITTALS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY MS SICK
WHERE DOES WHENEVER YOU ARE
READY. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN THE NINE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I'M PRESIDENT OF
THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY A STATEWIDE POLICY
RESEARCH AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION THAT HAS BEEN
DEDICATED TO ENSURING THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE AN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND. AND
SUCCEEDED IN COLLEGE I FIRST
LIKE TO START BY RECOGNIZING
THE SITUATION WE FIND OURSELVES
AND THINKING YOU. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY REMOTELY I'D ALSO
LIKE TO THANK CHAIRMAN ENOUGH
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE AND SO MANY ON HIGHER
EDUCATION IN OUR STATE. TIMES
LIKE THIS ROOM ME THERE REALLY.
BEFORE HAS WITH ITS IT'S AN IT.
OUR STATE ECONOMY DEMAND MORE
FOR. AND NEED TO SOME OF THE
TO. OUR RENOWNED PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM AND TO BE
SUCCESSFUL THEIR- SAFEGUARDING
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY HAS BEEN
CRITICAL TO OUR STATE ECONOMIC
STRENGTH AND WILL CERTAINLY BE
VITAL KERR RECOVERY FROM THIS
PANDEMIC. THAT'S CHANGES TO OUR-
TORSO UNIV. ARE SIGNIFICANT AND
WARRANT STATE LEVEL ENGAGEMENT
AB NINETEEN THIRTY RECOGNIZES
THIS AND WOULD PROVIDE THE
STATE AND STUDENTS WITH A MORE
THOUGHTFUL. CO HE SAID AND
EIGHT PROCESSOR WHEN
UNIVERSITIES CONSIDER CHANGING
THEIR ADMISSIONS REQUIREMENTS.
THE STATE HAS AN INTEREST IN
ENSURING THAT IT'S SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN HIGHER EDUCATION
RESULTS IN A FAIR AND EQUITABLE
ADMISSIONS PROCESS FOR THE
STUDENTS OF OUR STATE. THE
PUBLIC ALSO DEMANDS AND DEMANDS
THAT HIGHER EDUCATION AND OUR
K. TWELVE SCHOOL SHOULD BE
WORKING TOGETHER. WE HAVE A
COMMON GOAL WITH CHAIR MEDINA
AND SUPPORT AT THIS BILL IT IS
ACT ACCESS TO OUR PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES NOT JUST
INSTITUTION INTEREST. MANY OF
YOU ARE AWARE OF THE RECENT
STEPS THE CSU WHEN YOU SEE HAVE
TO OVER THE LAST YEAR TO
CONSIDER OR PROPOSED
SIGNIFICANT. TO EACH OF THEIR.
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS. AND
FOR IN THE CASE OF ONE OF THE
PROPOSAL THE PROCESS. A LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY IN APPROPRIATE
CONSULTATION. WITH CRITICAL
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WOULD BE
IMPACTED BY THE CHANGE TO
ELIGIBILITY. INCLUDING STUDENTS
IN OUR K. TWELVE SYSTEM K.
TWELVE LEADERS AND STAKEHOLDERS
POLICYMAKERS AND OF COURSE THE
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
THEMSELVES. POLICIES THAT
IMPACT THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS ABILITY TO PURSUE
THEIR COLLEGE DREAMS OF THE
STATE SHOULD NOT MADE WITHIN
THE CONFINES OF ONE INSTITUTION.
ABOUT A FULL VISION OF HOW THE
YEAR. BY DEBT THAT IT. WHAT
OTHER WERE CAN. AND THAT IN OF
THE CHIU. WILL DANCE IN THE
FARM OF OUR STATE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN THE AND- BE.
WILLOW INCOME STUDENTS ARE LAST
NIGHT. BLACK NAY AMERICAN AND
SOUTH ASIAN STUDENTS BE JUST
FOR. AND THE ANSWER BE NO AND
WE ENSURE ACROSS. ASSURE US
THAT ANSWER IS NOW. IN THE CASE
OF THE CSU PROPOSAL EARLIER
THIS YEAR IT WAS CRITICAL TO
UNDERSTAND WHO WOULD BE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BUT
IT WASN'T UNTIL STUDY
INDEPENDENTLY COMMISSION BY
EDUCATION ADVOCATES INCLUDING
THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY. THAT WE CONFIRM
THE STUDENTS MOST LIKELY TO
BEAR THE BRUNT OF THE PROPOSED
CHANGE WOULD HAVE BEEN STUDENTS
FROM THE NORTH SIERRA CENTRAL
VALLEY SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. WELL
AS IN MY HOUSE AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT THAT SHOULD BE CAN
THEN THE CON OF THE PROPOSAL.
OUR FIRST THREE. WORLD I'M MORE.
THAN EVER WE ALL KNOW CRITICAL
AN INCREASE VALUE OF A COLLEGE
EDUCATION IN OUR- WITHOUT A
STATE HIGHER EDUCATION COURTNEY
BODY TEXAS. THE KIND OF CREE
INTO MEANT CONVERSE. WHERE HAVE.
IT BECOMES INCOME UPON OUR
UNIVERSE TO A- CO HE SEVEN.
PROCESS IS DONE. WHEN CONSIDER
THE- AB THIRTY AS CLEAR. FOR
HOW THE FEAR AND YOU HE-
CONSIDER A DOG AND IN NEW
ELIGIBLE REQUIREMENTS AND MOVED
CLOSE TO AN THAT DO DEL. IS
DONE ON BEHALF OF. DENSON
FAMILY. BEING YOU AND I RISK
URGE AYE VOTE. THANK YOU WITH.
MODERATOR SECOND LEAD WHITNEY
CALLED IT. GIVE A SENIOR LOW
AND SO SHE AT THE EDUCATE TRUST
WEST MISSED RODRIGUEZ WHENEVER
YOU ARE READY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON HIGH
CHARITY TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MINDS MANUAL BUT HE GETS HERE
ON BEHALF HAT YOU TRUST WHAT
BIRDS LIKE TO THINK IT'S A IN
THE- AND THE MANY AUTHOR FOR
THEIR- AND COMMIT TO EDGE. ALSO
LIKE TO ECHO IT BACK INTO LAW
OF THE COMEDY CLUB. THE COLLEGE
UP TO JUST. SHE I WOULD OFFER
TO ADD THAT THOSE PRINCIPLES
SPOKE TO ALL INCLUSIVE TRAIN.
KALAU AND ACT MUST OFTEN IN OUR
K. TWELVE SYSTEM AND- WILL BE
HAVE WE AND BY ANY OF. CHANGE
THE FACT IS THAT CAL AS SYSTEM
TODAY OUR INADEQUATELY AN
INEQUITABLE OR- AND ANY CHANGE
TO OUR- REQUIRED WILL FURTHER
MARCH DO OF COLOR. KNOWING
STUDENTS STUDENTS REGISTERED.
AND ENGLISH. FOR THE ARTICLE
WOULD ALREADY BE. A TEACHER
SHORE BEFORE KOBE. THE PROPOSAL
CAN BE WRITTEN WITHOUT
SIGNIFICANT AND MEANINGFUL
INPUT FROM TWO TWELVE EDUCATORS
EXPERTS ON THE EXACT FACTORED I
JUST SPOKE TO. THIS BILL WAS
SURE THAT WE DO NOT REPEAT THIS
MISTAKE. ADDITIONALLY THESE
ELIGIBILITY CHANGES NEED TO BE
EQUITY CENTERED AND STUDENT
CENTER THE DEMAND FOR THIS HAS
ONLY BEEN MAGNIFIED BUT A CODED
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WHAT WE SEE
LOW INCOME STUDENTS DUKE OF
COLLEGE STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. ENGLISH LEARNERS
AND WORLD JOINS ALL BEING
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED. WE
MUST ENSURE THAT ANY CHANGES DO
NOT FURTHER JEOPARDIZE
EQUITABLE ACCESS FOR THE
STUDENTS. INCLUDING EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THIRTY WHAT CHECK ALL
OF THESE BOXES BY ENSURING THAT
ANY STUDENT ELIGIBILITY POLICY
CHANGE TO THE UC OR CSU SYSTEMS
WHAT HAVE THE GUARD RAILS IN
PLACE TO ENSURE INCLUSIVE AND
EQUITABLE FRAMEWORK SO THAT ALL
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY STUDENTS OF
COLOR LOW INTEREST GIVEN WHAT
HAPPENED BACK SHOT AT POST
SECONDARY EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES AND THE FACT.
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
ABOUT. THANK YOU MS MAD
BRIGADES WE WILL NOW MOVE THE
PUBLIC COMMENT ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBER FLOOR IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION POSITION. NOT
SEEN ANY ARE THEIR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER FLOOR OR IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. NOT
SEEING ANY ARE THERE ANY
TWEETERS IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER FLOOR OR IN THE GALLERY.
NOT SEEN ANY. MOVING TO THE
PHONE LINES AT AND T. MODERATOR
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE OR IN THE
QUEUE. AS A REMINDER IT IS ONE
ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO QUEUE UP
OUR FIRST LINE MORE OPENING HIS
LINE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AT THE DAY OF THE
TEACHER THAT IS THAT BROWN BOTH
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MORE
THAN. THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
EDUCATORS IN OUR STATE THE
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
PLEASED. THAT THE PORT AB
NINETEEN THIRTY. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE GO TO THE LINE FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS MY VALLEY KINCAID WITH
PUBLIC ADVOCATE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO THE
LINE OF NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SYLVIA
POLICE SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE
OVER TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO THE LINE EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. REPORTER OF THREE
COLLEGES AND CATTLE BUILDING
THAT KIND OF. I SUPPORT AB
THAN. NINETEEN THIRTY IF YOU
ARE WRONG BUT I THINK WE NEED
TO GET AB TWENTY TWO FOR
PASSPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT UP HERE IN THE CAN HI SO
CLOSE ON THE WITH THE UC
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. I THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MOVING TO THE
NEXT WILL GO TO LINE NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NOBODY WITH THE A. S.
I. BOARD DIRECTORS OF
SACRAMENTO STATE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY.
THANK YOU. NEXT IS MINE SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND A BARN BUT THE
NATIONAL. SOCIAL WORKER AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND
LAST IS LINE NINETY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CANNELLA BUT ON WHAT THE
WIDENING GROUP ARE PISSINGNEXT
IN CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MODERATOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ARE THERE
ANY WHICH IS TIMES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE OR IN
THE QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU DO
HAVE WOULD LIKE TO UP IT'S ONE
ZERO. ONE MOMENT WE DO HAVE ONE.
AND IT COMES FROM LINE EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ERIC
POCKET WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY. AT THE CSU
HAS BEEN OPPOSE POSITION ON THE
BILL- BEFORE I BEGIN I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THE WORK ON THIS BILL. AND
WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE- WITH US
DURING THESE CHALLENGING TIMES.
ADDITIONALLY WE ALSO LIKE TO
THANK CHAIRMAN DEAN THE FIRST
COMMITMENT TO HIGHER EDUCATION
ALWAYS SUPPORTING OUR STUDENTS
AND FINING PATHWAYS THAT WILL
LEAD TO THEIR SUCCESS. WITH
THAT SAID IT'S NOT EASY TO
OPPOSE ANY BILL PUT FORTH BY
GERMAN DINA. AT THE OP THERE IS
MENTION THE IMPETUS FOR THE
BILL IN PART- OR THE ACTIONS
TAKEN BY THE CSU BOARD OF
TRUSTEES IN JANUARY TO REQUIRE
AN ADDITIONAL YEAR WANTED KATE
OF REASONING. AS PART OF THE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS YES
YOU. SIR COULD YOU MENTION BY
THE BOARD BENEFITTED SIR COULD
YOU WRAP UP YOUR COMMENTS. I'M
SORRY BUT THERE'D BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR OPPOSITION. YES
SIR THERE IS THERE WERE. GOING
PRETTY FAST HERE. AB OUT TRY TO
KEEP WITHIN MY TWO MINUTES IS
THAT OKAY. PLEASE GO ANOTHER
TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR. BOB CAN BE AT AS THE
AUTHOR MENTIONS THE IMPETUS THE
BILL WAS IN PART THE ACTIONS
TAKEN BY THE CSU BOARD OF
TRUSTEES IN JANUARY TO REQUIRED
ADDITIONAL YEAR QUANTITATIVE
REASONING AS PART OF THE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS OF THE
CSU. BY THE BOARD BENEFIT FROM
STAKEHOLDER INPUT AND HAVE BEEN
REVISED ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS
BEFORE AN- IMPLEMENTATION PLAN.
WAS ADOPTED THIS PAST JANUARY.
AS WE EVALUATE AB NINETEEN
THIRTY WE FIND THAT THERE ARE A
LOT OF SIMILARITIES THE PLAN
THAT WE'VE ALREADY IMPLEMENTED
SUCH AS FIFTY IF YOU WILL BE
INCORPORATING A STEERING
COMMITTEE TO PROVIDE
IMPLEMENTATION GUIDANCE. AND
PROVIDE AND MONITORED METRIC TO
ASSESS THE IMPACT AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
REQUIREMENT. IS INTENDED THAT
THE STEERING COMMITTEE WOULD BE
MADE UP OF MULTIPLE
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING STATE
OFFICIAL PK TWELVE- DISTRICT
PERSONNEL STUDENTS FACULTY AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. INCREASED
TRANSPARENCY THROUGH THE MIDDLE
OF ANNUAL REPORTS TO A BOARD
TRUSTEES AND AN EXTRA REVIEW BY
A NONPARTISAN RESEARCH
ORGANIZATION TO INFIRM INFORM
THE AND IMPLEMENTATION. OVER
EIGHTY NINETEENTH WOULD APPLY
REQUIREMENTS TO NOT ONLY
CHANGES TO EIGHT EIGHT THREE
JUNE POLICIES. BUT ANY AND ALL
ELIGIBILITY ADMISSIONS
POLICIES. AB NINETEEN THIRTY AS
WELL INTENTIONED AND SPEAKS TO
ENSURE EQUITY AND ACCESS FOR
ALL STUDENTS. WE BELIEVE IT'S
OVERLY BROAD AND NOT WARRANTED
IN EVERY CIRCUMSTANCE. FINALLY
AT THE END OUT THE STATE WE
SHOULD STRIVE TO ENSURE THE
INDIAN MISSION OR ELIGIBILITY
POLICIES HAVE BEEN THOROUGHLY
VETTED PRIOR TO ADOPTION. WE
CAN HER. WE BELIEVE THE
APPROACH TO SEE IF YOU HAVE
ALREADY ADOPTED REFLECTS THE
GOALS IN THE INTENT OF AB
NINETEEN THIRTY. AND ESTABLISH
A BLUEPRINT FOR FUTURE
DISCUSSION. AT THE TIME WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
DIALOGUE- WITH THE AUTHOR AND
THE COMMITTEE AT THIS BILL
MOVES FOR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITE
IN SIR MODERATOR IS THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN THE QUEUE.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q. THANK
YOU MODERATOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES WHO ARE TWEETERS ON
THE PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE.
MODERATOR ONE WELL YOU HAVE
OKAY WE DO HAVE ONE WE DO HAVE
ONE IN Q. PARDON ME THAT COMES
ON THE LINE OF SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES SIR. HI
THIS IS TYLER ARE YOU ON THE AT
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA I'M
CALLING AT THE TWEETER SO I
WASN'T ABLE TO HEAR WHO'S
OPPOSITION OR TWITTER I KNOW I
NOTICED THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
WRAP IT UP SO KEEP IT RATHER
QUICK THANK YEAH MILLION
MEMBERS FOR HEARING THE BILL-
YOU SEE YOU'RE NOT HAVING MORE
WITH THIS NON THE BILL YET BUT
THE UNIVERSITY DOES HAVE
CONCERNS- THAT THE BILL MAY BE
TO EXPAND FROM APPLICATION AT
THIS TIME- WE UNDERSTAND. G. O.
G. POLICY AND CONTACT THAT WANT
TO PROVIDE. A QUICK UPDATE. I
RECENTLY THE UC ACADEMIC SENATE
HAS- MADE THAT USE TI.
MAINTAINED IN THE AREA DE
REQUIREMENT WHICH IS THE
EIGHTEEN. EIGHTY G. EXCUSE ME
SCIENCE REQUIREMENT FOR-
CREATED G. AREA DE. AT TWO
YEARS REQUIRED THREE YEARS
RECOMMENDED. AND THE UNIVERSITY
ADMINISTRATION CAN. ACTION SO
AGAIN WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
IMMEDIATE PLANS TO THE CHEST
AREA DE REQUIREMENTS. FOR A TO
G. ELEGY POP ELIGIBILITY
POLICY- MORE BROADLY AT THIS
TIME AGAIN WE APPRECIATE MISTER
DEAN AS- COMMITMENT TO EQUITY
LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH THEM. ON
AB NINETEEN THIRTY. IDEA THANK
YOU FOR CALM MODERATOR THEIR OF
TWEENER ON THE FOR OR INDICATE.
NO FURTHER TRAINERS IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU MODERATOR. TO
THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. YES SIR.
YEAH THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR AND ALSO THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING THIS
THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATION I
REALLY STRUGGLED WITH THIS
BILL- I DON'T UNFORTUNATELY I'M
GONNA BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY- I THINK THAT WHAT WE SAW
THIS YEAR'S USE PROPOSAL WAS A
WAY TO. ACHIEVE THE GOAL THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS ASKED OF IT
WHICH IS TO SPEED UP GRADUATION
RATES AND SO THEY WANTED TO
FIND A WAY TO PREPARE STUDENTS
BETTER FOR WHEN THEY WOULD GET
TO COLLEGE SO THAT THEY COULD-
COMPLETE COLLEGE THEN DROPPING
OUT. AND THEY SEND COMMUNITY
WHICH IS YOU KNOW WHAT WE
REALLY WANT OUR INSTITUTIONS TO
DO A PARTICULARLY LA U. S. D.
WHICH SAID WE JUST SIMPLY CAN'T
PROVIDE THESE CLASSES RIGHT NOW
I WHICH IS VERY SAD TO HEAR US
YES YOU HEARD THAT THEY CHANGED
THEIR RECOMMENDATION AND- AND
SO THEY'RE NOT IMPLEMENTING
THAT REQUIREMENT- AT THE TIME
THAT THEY WANTED TO. WHICH IS
GOING TO HURT OUR ABILITY TO
GET TO THE GRADUATION RATE GOAL
THAT WE HAVE AND OF COURSE TO
GET O. THE WORK FORCE THAT WE
WANT CALIFORNIA TO HAVE. FOR
THE FUTURE GENERATION OF
CALIFORNIAN THE ECONOMIC MIGHT
OF THE STATE AND ENGAGE
CITIZENRY. THAT THE STATE
DESERVES. I WANT TO THROW OPEN
THE GATES OF HIGHER EDUCATION
TO EVERYBODY. I ABSOLUTELY DO
AND- AND SO WE HAVE AS AS- IN
OUR JOBS IN THE PAST FEW YEARS.
DONE EVERYTHING WE CAN TO DO
THAT CREATE MORE SEATS
AVAILABLE AT CSU. AND YOU SEE
AND MAKE OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AS AFFORDABLE AS IT CAN BE YOU
KNOW FREE EXCEPT FOR YOUR COST
OF LIVING. AND I AND THERE ARE
SO MANY WAYS FOR STUDENTS EVEN
IF THEY DON'T MEET THIS
QUANTITATIVE REASONING
REQUIREMENT IF IT WAS IN PLACE.
TO CONTINUE THROUGH WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHICH IS
PROBABLY THE SMARTEST
EDUCATIONAL CHOICE ANY
CALIFORNIAN CAN MAKE IS TO GO
TO CATCH A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FOR THEIR FIRST TWO YEARS. AND
DIED AND THAT DOESN'T CHANGE
PARTICULARLY NOW IN LIGHT OF
THE MOMENT THAT WERE IN. AND I
SPEAK NOT JUST AS A POLICYMAKER
BUT I SPEAK WITH SOMEONE WITH A
GREAT DEAL OF EXPERIENCE. WITH
ROAD BLOCKS TO GRADUATION. I AM
A GRADUATE OF CAL STATE
NORTHRIDGE. AND I NEEDED TO
TAKE REMEDIAL MATH. WHEN I GOT
TO CAL STATE NORTHRIDGE IT
WASN'T A SURPRISE. I GRADUATED
HIGH SCHOOL JUST FINE ON BUT-
WHEN I TOOK ALGEBRA TWO MY
TEACHER. WAS THE FOOTBALL COACH
AND THE P. E. TEACHER. AND HE
WAS A REALLY GOOD DRIVERS ED
TEACHER I HAD AN FOR DRIVER
SAID AS WELL. AND I IS THAT
DRIVERS ED EXAM. NO MY KIDS
MIGHT THINK I DIDN'T. BUT I DID
NOT GET PREPARED FOR COLLEGE
LEVEL MATH. SHOCKER AND THAT'S
A STORY THAT I THINK A LOT OF
STUDENTS HAVE. ANY EXPERIENCE I
THINK THAT THIS YES YOU LISTEN
TO L. L. U. S. T. I. I DIDN'T
GO TO LAUSD SCHOOL- BUT- THAT
STUDENTS AREN'T GETTING THE
PREPARATION THEY NEED IN HIGH
SCHOOL. AND SO NOW THE CSU IS
DEALING WITH THAT CHALLENGE
THEY DEALT WITH IT WHERE I HAD
TO. TAKE REMEDIAL MATH ANY
NUMBER OF TIMES BECAUSE I DID
DROP OUT A FEW TIMES I
ACTUALLY. DID NOT PASS IT THE
FIRST TIME I TOOK IT I FINALLY
TOOK COLLEGE LEVEL MATH THE
FALL OF MY SENIOR YEAR I PUT IT
OFF AND PUT IT OFF. I DID JUST
FINE. I DID JUST FINDING
BECAUSE OF HIM ACTUALLY ENJOYED
THE CLASS BUT- BUT THIS YES YOU
LISTEN TO THAT EXPERIENCE AND
SAID THIS ISN'T HELPING OUR
STUDENTS GRADUATE AND IN FACT
WE CAN TEACH ALL OF THEM- AT AT
A COLLEGE LEVEL WITHOUT MAKING
AND TAKE WHAT ESSENTIALLY WAS A
AN OBSTACLE COURSE FOR ME. I
WHERE I HAD TO SPEND MONEY ON
CLASSES THAT DID NOT GIVE ME
COLLEGE CREDIT. AND SLOWED DOWN
AND SLOW DOWN HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS PROBABLY OVER THE
YEARS OF STUDENTS. FROM
GRADUATING AND TIMELY MANNER.
SO I BELIEVE THIS ISSUE IS
DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN. THE
SERVICE POPULATION. WILL
CALIFORNIA POPULATION BUT IF
YOU JUST LOOK AT THE DATA A
PARTICULARLY OF OUR-
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE ARE DOING
AMAZING IN GETTING MINORITY
STUDENTS TO GRADUATE DEGREES
THAT COME OUT OF THE CSU- SO.
THEY'RE DOING THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE ASKING OF THEM AND
THEY'RE TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE WORK
FOR. AND WE PEOPLE IN TIME AND
IN FACT THEY'RE DOING AS WE
HEARD ON THE CALL I DIDN'T EVEN
MEET WITH THEM ABOUT THIS I
JUST KNOW FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AND WHAT I'VE READ
THEY'RE DOING THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE ASKING THEM TO DO IN THIS
BILL. I DON'T MIND BELTS AND
SUSPENDERS- FOR GROUPS THAT WE
DON'T TRUST ON I KNOW THIS
YEAR'S HE'S WORKING REALLY HARD
ON THIS ISSUE AND- AND THAT'S
WHY TODAY AND REALLY SADLY YOU
KNOW I WRESTLED WITH THIS
OVERNIGHT I LISTEN TO. THE
TESTIMONY AND FOR SOME NOT ABLE
TO SUPPORT IT BUT I DO
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
THAT WE'RE HAVING THE GOAL THAT
WERE HAVING AND- OF MAKING SURE
THAT THE DOORS TO HIGHER AT OUR
OPEN EVERYONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER. YES I
WANT TO THANK. OUR CHAIR FOR
THIS BILL AND I'M ONE OF THE CO
OP IS ON THE BILL AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE BECAUSE- IN MANY WAYS
THEY ARE CORRECT TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE UNIVERSITY HAS-
LISTENED EVENTUALLY TO THE
AUDIENCE TO THE PUBLIC AND
DECIDED TO GO IN THAT DIRECTION
AND THAT AND THAT'S IMPORTANT.
I GUESS THE PROBLEM COMES IN IS
THAT THE TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
ENERGY THAT WAS EXPENDED AND
THE KIND OF ANXIETY CREATED AS
A RESULT OF THEM NOT HAVING THE
PROCESS AND NOT HAVING
INCLUSION OF THE PUBLIC-
COMMENTS AND RESEARCH IN
ADVANCE RATHER THAN AFTER THE
FACT YOU KNOW AFTER BEING
PRESSURE AND THE KIND OF
PUBLICITY AND ANXIETY THAT
STUDENTS AND- AND STAFFERS HAD
ABOUT THIS. WAS REALLY
UNNECESSARY WITH THEIR IT
ENGAGED IN THIS PROCESS OF THE
BEGINNING AND BASICALLY SOUGHT
OUT THE INFORMATION THAT WAS
NECESSARY THEN WE WOULDN'T HAVE
TO DEAL WITH THIS WOULD HAVE
HAD HEARINGS ON IT HERE AT THE
CAPITOL WOULD HAVE GONE TO ALL
THESE THINGS IN THE HEARING TO
REALLY WILL BY WERE BOB PROCESS
AND WHETHER THAT THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN ASKED. AND
SO FORTH AND SO ON AND SO THIS
BILL IS REALLY ABOUT NOT
NECESSARILY CONDEMNING THE
WOULD MAKING SURE THAT IN THE
FUTURE IF THERE ARE CHANGES AND
SHIFTS AND REQUIREMENTS THERE'S
A PROCESS IN PLACE THAT DIDN'T
DOES THIS SO THE WE DON'T FIND
OURSELVES ONCE AGAIN HAVING
LISTENED TO IT ON THE NEWS
FIGURE OUT WHO DID WHAT SO
FORTH AND SO ON BUT BASICALLY
ADDRESSED THE ISSUE AS IT
SHOULD BE YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT THE C. ISSUED TO THE
UC'S ARE WRESTLING WITH. ISSUE
OF ADMISSIONS AND
QUALIFICATIONS AND THE PROBLEM
LIES REALLY UNFORTUNATELY YEAH
IF THE WITH ALL OF THEM BECAUSE
I COULD SAY WELL TO KEEP TWELVE
ISSUE BECAUSE L. L. A. U. S. V.
COMES BACK AND SAYS WE CAN'T
OFFER THESE CLASSES WE DON'T
HAVE QUALIFIED STAFF. IF WE
HAVE NOT STUDENTS FOR THE
EDUCATED WHICH IS A FORTUNATE
THAT THEY HAVE NOT DONE THAT-
AND SO AS A RESULT NO YEAH IT'S
OUR K. TWELVE BUT THE I BACK UP
AND ALWAYS SAY TO EVERYBODY WHO
TRAIN ALL THE TEACHERS IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW AND
BASICALLY OVER 80% OF OUR
TEACHERS ARE MORE TRADE. BAR
SEE ISSUE AND USE STATE SO ARTS.
OF A- THAT OCCUR. BY UNIV. ARE
NOT ADDED. FOR OUR TEACHERS
WERE TEACHING MAP. AND SO FORTH
AND SO ON TO BASICALLY MEET THE
CHALLENGE SO. WE START POINTING
FINGERS AT ALL COMES BACK TO
ALL OF THAT. AND THEN IT COMES
BACK TO US BECAUSE WE HAVE NO
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM. AND HAVE
NOT DEALT WITH A HEART ISSUES
THE TEACHER CERTIFICATION. THE
TEACHER REQUIREMENT TEACHER AT
OF ASSESSMENT THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN AND THE EXPECTATIONS AND
HOLDING OUR OWN K. TWELVE
SYSTEM ACCOUNTABLE. SO EVERYONE
IS REALLY AT FAULT AT THIS
POINT AND THE LAST PERSON WHO
SHOULD PAY FOR. OTHER
STRUGGLING STUDENTS TO
ATTENDING OUR SCHOOLS. PUTTING
THEIR ENERGY INTO A THINKING
THAT WE'RE GIVING THEM THE BEST
THAT WE HAVE. AND WE'RE NOT AND
SO AS A RESULT THEY SHOULD BE
THE LAST ONES WHO BASICALLY
SUPPER. AND FIND THEMSELVES IN
A SITUATION OF HAVING TO GO TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IS A GREAT THIS IS THE
BILL. BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
SUCCESS RATE KIDS OF COLOR IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. IT IS NOT
THE GREATEST PLACE FOR THEM
BECAUSE THE MOST OF THEM DON'T
GRADUATE FROM A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE- GIVE VERY FEW EIGHTY
DEGREES WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT.
MANY OF THEM DROP OUT COME BACK
DROP OUT AND COME BACK BECAUSE
OF THE STRUCTURE AND WHAT HAVE
YOU. AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO
IMPROVE OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
BUT IT IS NOT THE FOR MANY
STUDENTS GOING TO A FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTION EVEN IF THEY
STRUGGLE. BECAUSE EVERYONE
THERE IS TRYING TO GET A DEGREE
THE END OF WITH FORCES. AT THE
FOUR YEAR. THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SO WE HAVE A LOT OF
CHALLENGES THAT WE NEED TO
MEET. BUT THE LAST PERSON WHO
SHOULD BASICALLY PAY FOR OUR
STUDENTS WILL PUT THEIR BEST
INTO WHAT WE GAVE THEM. AND
THEN FIND THEMSELVES SHORT. SO
I'M BACK TO ASTRONOMICAL. TO
THIS PARTICULAR BILL. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU AND MISTER
CHAIR TO HAVE CLOSING
STATEMENTS THANK YOU I THOUGHT
I'D LIKE TO THANK BOTH OF MY
COLLEAGUES WERE THERE- COMMENTS
AND DISCUSSION ON THIS BILL.
AND. TO THE- MY COLLEAGUES WHO
STRUGGLE WITH HIGH SCHOOL MATH.
I NEVER MADE IT TO THIRD YOUR
MATH IN HIGH SCHOOL. BECAUSE I
HAD SUCH A HARD TIME WITH WITH
THE SECOND YEAR OF YOUR
GEOMETRY. THE SECOND YEAR OF
HIGH SCHOOL MATH. TO THE
CHAGRIN OF MY FATHER THE CIVIL
ENGINEER. BUT I IT WAS
SUCCESSFUL IN COLLEGE- GOING TO
PREVIEW UNIVERSITY WHERE I
MAJORED FIRST AND POLITICAL
SCIENCE AND THEN IN HISTORY
WHEN I TRANSFERRED TO YOU SEE
YOU ARE. AND I WANT TO THANK
DOCTOR WEBER IN HER REMARKS
BECAUSE I THINK THE NECESSARY
CITY OF THIS BILL. IS THAT THE
CSU DID NOT ENGAGE THE CSU DID
NOT ENGAGE. EITHER WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. AND TELL THEY
REALLY HAD TO OR WITH THE K.
TELL K. TWELVE SYSTEM WITH THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION NOR WITH- K. TWELVE
DISTRICTS THEMSELVES. SO THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL I THINK
IT'S DOCTOR WEBER WELL POINTED
OUT IS TO ENSURE THAT THE NEXT
TIME. THE CSU- CONSIDERS
CHANGING THE A THROUGH G.
REQUIREMENTS IT WILL ENGAGE
WITH THOSE WHO WILL HAVE TO-
THERE- THE CHANGES AND THOSE
ARE THE K. TWELVE AND- AND THE
STUDENTS SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR FIVE OF. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
MEDINA HI VOEPEL HI VOEPEL I
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI BLOOM
BLOOM HI GABRIEL GABRIEL HI
IRWIN IRWIN HI KILEY. KILEY NOT
VOTING LEVINE LEVINE NO LOW LOW
HI PATTERSON. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
I WEBER WEBER HI. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS NINE ONE MISTER CHAIR
YOUR BILL IS OUT. IF WE COULD
HAVE NOW THE SECRETARY- CALL
THE BILLS THAT ARE ON CALL.
STARTING WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE BILLS ON CONSENT
AB TWO FOUR NINE FOUR AB THREE
THREE SEVEN FOUR AB TWO ZERO
ONE NINE AB TWO FIVE SEVEN
EIGHT AB TWO FOUR EIGHT FOUR
AND EIGHTY TWO ONE NINE ZERO
THAT WAS READ AND FILE ORDER
NOT BILL ORDER AGAIN THIS IS
THE CONSENT CALENDAR -ARAMBULA.
PATTERSON SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO HI
THE CURRENT ACCOUNT IS NOW TEN
ZERO. THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS PAST
DUE WOULD CONTINUE ON. MOVING
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TWO
THREE EIGHT EIGHT CHAIR VOTING
I'D SANTIAGO SANTIAGO. MISTER
CHAIR IT IS NOW TWELVE ZERO.
BILL IS OUT. MOVING TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TWO EIGHT
EIGHT FOUR SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
ONLINE. THE CURRENT ACCOUNT
MISTER CHAIR IS NOW TEN ONE.
THANK YOU THE BILL IS OUT.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB TWO ZERO THREE ZERO
THE CHAIR VOTING I'D SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO HI THE COUNT IS TWELVE
ZERO MISTER CHAIR BILL IS OUT.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
AB TWO FOUR ONE SIX SHARE
VOTING I'D SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
ONLINE THE COUNT IS NOW TWELVE
ZERO MISTER CHAIR THE BILL IS
OUT. MOVING THE FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE THE CHAIR VOTING
I'D VICE CHAIR NOT DEVOTING
PATTERSON. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
ALL RIGHT MISTER CHAIR THE
COUNT IS NOW NINE ONE. BILL IS
OUT. MOVING THE FILE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWO THREE FOUR
ONE CHAIR VOTING I'D SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HI MISTER CHAIR THE
COUNT IS NOW TWELVE ZERO BILL
IS OUT. MOVING THE FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN AB THREE ONE THREE
ZERO WE HAVE ALL PRESENT VOTING.
AND FILE ITEM TWELVE ALL ARE
PRESENT AND VOTING. THANK YOU.
I WANT TO EXTEND MY GRATITUDE
TO THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE THE
RULES COMMITTEE STAFF THE
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR AND ALL
WHO ENSURE THIS IN THIS HEARING
COULD TAKE PLACE ESPECIALLY
WHICH TO THANK MY COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK.
COMMITMENT AND DEDICATION.
FINALLY I'D LIKE TO REMIND
EVERYONE THAT DURING THESE
UNCERTAIN TIMES WE CAN TAKE
SOLACE IN THE FACT. THAT WE ARE
ALL IN THIS TOGETHER. THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE VISITOR.